OKAY OKAY. WELL GOOD GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE AND WELCOME TO
THE SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
STUDENT SUCCESS THIS IS A
FORMAL HEARING OF THE COMMITTEE
AND SO WE HAVE A- SAYS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE SENATE WHERE WE
TAKE TESTIMONY BUT WE ALWAYS.
PROVIDE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT SO. I THANK YOU
ALL THOSE WHO HAVE COME HERE
TODAY FILLED THE ROOM. TO
LISTEN TO SOME WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCED. FOLKS SHARE THEIR
THOUGHTS WITH US ABOUT STUDENT
SUCCESS BUT IF YOU HAVE AN
OPINION THAT YOU'D LIKE TO
SHARE. AT THE END OF OUR
HEARING WE WELCOME YOU TO COME
TO THE MICROPHONE AND SHARE.
THOSE THOUGHTS. BUT IT'S REALLY
GREAT TO BE HERE TODAY AT THE
CAL POLY POMONA CAMPUS YOU'RE
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS I WAS LAST
YEAR. FORTY YEARS AGO. I WAS
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AT SAN
DIEGO STATE AND AS A PART OF
THE CSSA WE- WOULD ROTATE THE
CAMPUSES AND- HAD MANY
OCCASIONS TO COME HERE AT THIS
BEAUTIFUL CAMPUS. I SEE SOME
CHANGES I SEE SOME THINGS THAT.
STILL SEEM THE SAME. THAT COW
IS STILL THERE I KNOW THAT
COUNTS. BUT THE HEARING ON
STUDENT SUCCESS IS PART OF OUR
TWO YEAR STATEWIDE TOUR OF
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. EXPLORING
STUDENT NEEDS AND THEIR ABILITY
TO SUCCEED IN THE CLASSROOM.
LAST SPRING WE VISITED
SACRAMENTO STATE. THIS WEEK
YESTERDAY ACTUALLY WE WERE CAL.
C. S. U. DOMINGUEZ HILLS. AND
VISITING WITH THE LEADERSHIP
THERE. AND I APPRECIATE THE
WARM WELCOME MANY HERE FROM
YOUR PRESIDENT HERE IN A FEW
MINUTES BUT THANK YOU TO HER
AND- THE WONDERFUL STAFF HERE
AT POMONA. FOR THE ENGAGING.
DISCUSSIONS IN THE WARM WELCOME
THAT WE HAVE HAD. I'M JOINED
HERE BY TWO OF MY ESTEEMED.
COLLEAGUES IN THE SENATE
SENATOR LING LING CHANG. AND
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH WE'RE
GONNA GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SAY SOME THINGS HERE IN A
FEW MINUTES THEY'D LIKE. THE
MISSION OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON STUDENT SUCCESS. IS TO
GATHER EXPERTS FOR DISCUSSION.
NOT TO PUSH A SPECIFIC AGENDA.
BUT DISCUSSION TO LEARN. BEST
PRACTICES. AND INNOVATIONS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT SUCCESS. OUR
FOCUS IS ON STUDENTS AND
PUTTING THEM ON A PATH. TO A
SUCCESSFUL GRADUATION. AT THIS
HEARING WE INTEND TO EXPLORE A
GROWING CRISIS FACING STUDENTS.
AS THEY JUGGLE CLASSROOM
CHALLENGES. AND THEIR ABILITY
TO GRADUATE ON TIME. AND FOR ME
THAT'S FOUR YEARS. BUT TO DO SO
WITH MANY OTHER ISSUES IN THEIR
WORLD THAT MAYBE WEREN'T AROUND
WHEN AS MUCH WHEN I WAS A
STUDENT THAT'S ISSUES OF
HUNGER. ISSUES OF MENTAL
HEALTH. ISSUES OF HOMELESSNESS.
STUDENTS WHO STRUGGLE WITH
BASIC NEEDS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
STRUGGLE WITH THAT. GOAL OF
GRADUATION COMPARED TO THOSE
WHO DON'T HAVE THE SAME ISSUES.
AND EVEN STUDENTS WHO DON'T
FACE HEALTH AND HOUSING AND
BASIC NEED ISSUES. OFTEN ARE
STILL MET WITH OBSTACLES TO
GRADUATION. TERMS OF BEING ABLE
TO GET THE COURSES THAT THEY
NEED TO GRADUATE ON TIME. WE
ARE GOING TO HEAR FROM THAT.
THE EXPERTS AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AS
TERMS OF HOW WE ARE DOING ON
GRADUATION RATES THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE SYSTEM. AND THE SUPPORT
AND SUCCESS OF THE CAL PROMISE
PROGRAM WE PASSING LEGISLATION
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. AND WE
DO SEE A LOT OF DIFFERENCES
AMONG CAMPUSES. AND I LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THOSE THAT ARE DOING
A PARTICULARLY GOOD JOB AND
THAT'S SACRAMENTO STATE AND SAN
JOSE STATE THEY HAVE THOUSANDS
OF THEIR KIDS INVOLVED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PHOENICIAN
FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT NAMES
FOR IT. PROGRAM ON THEIR
CAMPUSES. AND THEIR GRADUATION
RATE NUMBERS ARE IMPROVING
DRAMATICALLY ONLY GREAT TO SEE
THAT. AND HERE POMONA E.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF POSITIVE
PROGRESS I'M SURE THE
PRESIDENT'S CAN SPEAK TO IT. I
IN TERMS OF FOR YOUR GRADUATION
RATES SIX YOUR GRADUATION RATES
THE- THE ODD THE GAP BETWEEN
UNDER REPRESENTED AND EVERYONE
ELSE IN TERMS OF WHO SUCCEEDING
AND WHO'S NOT. AND I WANT TO
GIVE DO PRAISE TO THE CAMPUS
THE CAMPUS LEADERSHIP IN THE
FACULTY. FOR THE WORK THAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS TO ACCOMPLISH THAT. BUT I
ALSO SEE SOME GAPS GAPS IN NOW.
AVAILABILITY OF THE PROMISE
PROGRAM THE STUDENTS HERE COME
ON AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING TESTIMONY. FEEDBACK
ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S NOT
WORKING AND OF COURSE WHAT WE
CAN DO IN THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE. OF A GREAT CAMPUS I
LIKE CAL POLY POMONA. FOR
SOMEONE LIKE TO INVITE MY
COLLEAGUES HERE FROM THE SENATE
TO SAY ANY OPENING REMARKS AT
LIKE TO MAKE AND THEN I WANT
TO. INTRODUCE OUR WONDERFUL
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS CENTER
CHANG ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO
SAY TO BEGIN. YES FOR SOMEONE
OF THINKCENTRE GLAZER FOR
BRINGING THIS COMMITTEE COULD
HELP HOLLY. I ACTUALLY LIVE
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILES AWAY
SO. I'M NEARBY AND WHEN I WAS
ON THE DIAMOND BAR CITY
COUNCIL. I SERVED ON THE CAL
POLY POMONA NATIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL AS WELL AS
THE PARTNERS IN EDUCATION FOR
MANY MANY YEARS OF THIS. THIS
CAMPUS IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY-
HEART. I'M ALSO PLEASED TO
SERVE ON THE COMMITTEE
ALONGSIDE CENTER ROTH WHO
CHAIRS THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CAREER TECHNOLOGY IN THE NEW
ECONOMY WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
C. T. THAT'S THE PIPELINE FROM
K. TWELVE TO THE C. ISSUE AS IT
RELATES TO. YOU KNOW CAREER
TECH EDUCATION. FINALLY I WANT
TO THANK PRESIDENT COLEY FOR
HOSTING US HERE WE HAVE A LOT
TO LEARN FROM CAL POLY. I AM
ALSO VERY INTERESTED IN.
EVERYTHING THAT SENATOR GLAZER
HAS MENTIONED IN TERMS OF FOOD
AND SECURITY AS WELL AS HEARING
FROM MAKE A HUNTER. AS A
STUDENT HERE. I ATE. AT I TOUR
THE CAMPUS I THINK IT WAS THE
END OF LAST YEAR I BELIEVE AND
I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH WHAT
THEY'RE DOING SO I'M LOOKING
FOR TO THIS CONVERSATION THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU SENATOR
CHANG AND SENATOR ROBB THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR GREAT LEADERSHIP ON
HIGHER EDUCATION. I SAW YOU.
WERE THERE WITH THE GOVERNOR
YESTERDAY. I CARRY FOR ME I WAS.
HE DID A REALLY GOOD JOB AND WE
ALL OF US TOGETHER SUPPORTERS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION BUT A
REALLY AMAZING THING HAPPENED
YESTERDAY WASN'T JUST THAT
SENATOR ROTH CENTER SHANG. A
PASSING HISTORIC LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE OVER SIX BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
FACILITIES MEASURE THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOME SIGNED
YESTERDAY CENTER ROTH THANK YOU
FOR REPRESENTING ME THERE. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
THE CENTER ROTH CHAIRS THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION AND IT'S BEEN A GREAT
CHAMPION AND GREAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE. THANK YOU MISTER I SAID
COVERING FOR SENATOR GLAZER
BECAUSE YOU MAY NOT KNOW IT
BUT- SENATOR GLAZER WAS CO
AUTHOR ON THAT FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLAR. BOND MEASURE THAT THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED YESTERDAY AND
HE WAS BUSY A HEARING FROM
OTHERS ON ANOTHER C. ISSUE
CAMPUSES A CALL. AS PART OF
THIS COACH DURING HIS SELECT
COMMITTEE PROCESS BUT I WAS
PRIVILEGED TO STAND IN FOR HIM
ONLY. HALF OF SENATE GLAZER BUT
I DID THE BEST I COULD. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME FOR INCLUDING
THE CENTER FOR INCLUDING ME ON
YOUR ALLOWING ME TO SIT ON YOUR
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR TODAY.
ABOUT THIS AS YOU MAY KNOW THIS
IS MY FIRST YEAR. INCLUDING MY
FIRST YEAR. DEALING WITH THE
EDUCATION BUDGET CASE THROUGH
HIGHER EDUCATION. IN SACRAMENTO
AND IT'S BEEN QUITE A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE FOR ME. AND A
VARIETY OF WAYS AND ONE OF THEM
IS THE TREMENDOUS NEED THAT WE
HAVE OUT THERE. FOCUSING JUST
ON HIGHER EDUCATION THE
TREMENDOUS NEED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION MORE MONEY. FOR
GRADUATION INITIATIVES. MORE
MONEY FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND
COUNSELING ON CAMPUSES BOTH
FACILITIES AND PERSONNEL.
DEALING WITH HOUSING ISSUES AND
HUNGER AND HOW WE- STRUGGLE TO.
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET YET
PROVIDE FOR THOSE VERY VERY
ESSENTIAL THINGS THAT. THAT OUR
STUDENTS THE FUTURE. OF OUR
GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEED
IN ORDER TO SUCCEED SO I THINK
I'LL STOP TALKING AND SWITCH TO
LISTENING MODE TODAY. TO PAY
ATTENTION CAREFULLY TO ALL THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO TALK TO US
ABOUT. TAKE THAT BACK TO
SACRAMENTO WITH MY COLLEAGUES
AND- SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS. THIS
GREAT INSTITUTION FOR WITH
TAKING THE PICTURE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH. I WORE HERE ON
THE BEAUTIFUL CAL POLY POMONA
CAMPUS. WE HAVE A WONDERFUL
PRESIDENT DOCTOR SERAYA HOLLY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE YOU'RE
THE SIX PRESIDENT HERE AT CAL
POLY POMONA. IT'S AMAZING AND
ALL THE YEARS JUST SIX. AND
THIS IS JIM ABOUT A WONDERFUL
PLACE IT IS THE LEAD. BUT YOU
TOOK OFFICE IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. DURING YOUR
TENURE GUIDE YOU ENROLLMENTS
GOING OVER A COUPLE THOUSAND
ALREADY HERE ON THE CAMPUS
WHICH IS A I KNOW PRIDEFUL
THING. AND YOUR FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATES OF GROUND
CONSISTENTLY CONGRATULATIONS
FOR THAT. AND YOU CONTINUE TO
BUILD A ON A REPUTATION FOR
MAKING THE CAMPUS ACCESSIBLE.
TO DIVERSE AND DYNAMIC STUDENT
POPULATION. I KNOW THAT YOU.
COME TO YOUR POSITION WITH A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE AND ACADEMIC
LEADERSHIP. AND IT'S GREAT TO
BE HERE WITH YOU AND WE. HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR GLACIER AND SENATE
CHANG AND SENATOR ROTH FOR
JOINING US AND HOLDING. THIS
HEARING TODAY. WE ALSO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL AND
COLLECTIVE COMMITMENT TO
STUDENT SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
CHANCES OFFICE REPRESENTATIVES.
OUR FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS
WHO WERE IN ATTENDANCE AT THE
HEARING. AS WELL AS THOSE
JOINING US VIA THE LIVESTREAM.
IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO TALK TODAY
ABOUT THE PROGRESS BEING MADE
ACCOUNT HOLLY POMONA AND OUR
COMPREHENSIVE AND COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH TO STUDENT SUCCESS.
CAMPAGNA MONA IS A CAMPUS ON
THE MOVE. JEFF SENSE TWENTY CAN
I'M ROWLAND HAS GROWN BY MORE
THAN A QUARTER WHICH MEANS THAT
NEARLY SIX THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS ARE BENEFITING FROM A
WORLD CLASS KALPANA MONNING
EDUCATION TODAY COMPARED TO A
DECADE AGO. AND DURING THAT
SAME TIME PERIOD THE NUMBER OF
INCOMING TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE
ROLLING EACH YEAR HAS MORE THAN
DOUBLED. NOTABLY OUR INCOMING
CLASS OF SEVEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED STUDENTS THIS FALL WAS
ROUGHLY HALF FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN AND HALF TRANSFER
STUDENTS. THIS COMMITMENT TO
ACCESS COMBINED WITH OUR
INCLUSIVE POLYTECHNIC EDUCATION
IS UNIQUELY PREPARING STUDENTS
FOR SUCCESS LONG AFTER THEY
LEAVE OUR CAMPUS. CONSIDER THE
VARIOUS RANKINGS MEASURING
SOCIAL MOBILITY WHETHER IT'S IN
THE US NEWS ANALYSIS THE SOCIAL
MOBILITY INDEX OR THE RESEARCH
TEAM AT HARVARD. CAL POLY
POMONA RANKS IN THE TOP TEN IN
HE- A TESTAMENT TO OUR HARD
WORKING STUDENTS AND THE
LEARNING THAT TAKES PLACE ON
OUR CAMPUS. WE HAVE A GUIDING
PRINCIPLE ACCOUNTTYPE MONA THAT
SAYS ONE TEAM ONE GOAL STUDENT
SUCCESS AND THE TESTIMONY TODAY
YOU WILL HEAR THIS PHRASE
REPEATED. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
YOU WILL SEE HOW IT MANIFEST IN
OUR PROGRAMS AND OUR PROJECTS.
THROUGHOUT THE PANEL COMMENTS
TODAY WE WERE REFERRED TO THE
COMPONENTS OF OUR INTEGRATED
MODEL OF STUDENT SUCCESS AND
YOU WILL SEE THAT LINE. ON THE
SCREEN BUT I THINK YOU ALSO
HAVE IT AVAILABLE IN YOUR
PACKAGE. AS AN ACTION STAFF OF
OUR ACADEMIC MASTER PLAN WE
CREATED THIS MODEL TO
CONCEPTUALIZE OUR WHOLE LISTING
APPROACH TO STUDENT LEARNING
ENGAGEMENT AND GROWTH. EACH
PIECE OF THE OUTER RAIN
DESCRIBES AN ESSENTIAL ELEMENT
OF STUDENT SUCCESS WHEN TAKEN
TOGETHER THEY PUT OUR STUDENTS
ON A GUIDED PATHWAY TO SUCCESS
AT CAL POLY POMONA AND BEYOND.
BY INVESTING IN THE TOTAL
STUDENT WE CONNECT OUR ACADEMIC
MASTER PLAN TO OUR OVERARCHING
GOAL OF STUDENT SUCCESS. WHEN
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WAS LAUNCHED
WE SAW AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
MORE INTENTIONAL AND
COMPREHENSIVE IN OUR WORK
UTILIZING THE RESOURCE IS
CONNECTED TO THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE WE HAVE FOCUSED ON
ELIMINATING SILOS INCREASING
COLLABORATION STRENGTHENING OUR
DATA ANALYTICS CAPABILITIES AND
REMOVING BARRIERS TO STUDENT
SUCCESS. AND WE ARE INVESTING
IN INNOVATION WITH PARTICULAR
EMPHASIS ON MOST PRESSING NEEDS
SUCH AS ADDING CLASS SECTIONS
BOWSTRING ADVISING AND
STRENGTHENING OUR BASIC NEEDS
CAPACITY. FOR EXAMPLE A CENTRAL
PIECE OF OUR STUDENT SUCCESS
AFTERWARDS WE HAVE EMBARKED ON
A FACULTY HIRING PLANS. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE
CONDUCTED FORTY FIVE TENURE
TRACK SEARCHES AND LAST YEAR WE
CONDUCTED FIFTY ONE FIFTY HAVE
BEEN APPROVED FOR THIS YEAR
SIMILARLY WE'RE COMMITTED TO
RETURNING TO PRE RECESSION TEN
YEAR DENSITY LEVELS. THE
PROGRAMS AND INITIATIVES YOU
WILL HEAR ABOUT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL TODAY
REPRESENT JUST A PORTION OF OUR
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE STUDENT
SUCCESS AND WELL BEING. WHAT IS
REPRESENTATIVE EXAMPLES THESE
ENDEAVORS TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
COMMITMENT TO DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING OUR FOCUS ON
INNOVATION OUR STEADFASTNESS
AND CAREFULLY MEASURING OUR
PROGRESS AND OUR COLLABORATIVE
APPROACH TO CONSIDERING THE
NEEDS OF THE WHOLE STUDENT. AND
EVEN AS WE CELEBRATE OUR
PROGRESS WE ARE MINDFUL OF THE
SERIOUS CHALLENGES WE FACE. I
REGRET THE NUMBER C. ISSUE
ALLEN JOEL STUDENTS THAT GOT
TURN THAT WERE TURNED AWAY FROM
OUR CAMPUS THIS FALL WE DENY
JUST OVER FIFTEEN THOUSAND C.
ISSUE ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS. IN
TERMS OF AFFORDABILITY THREE
FOURTHS OF OUR STUDENTS QUALIFY
FOR FINANCIAL AID BUT THE
AVERAGE AWARD IS ONLY ABOUT
HALF THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE WE ARE PROUD OF OUR
RECENT PROGRESS IN GRADUATION
RATES BUT ARE ALSO AWARE. THAT
WE BENEFITED FROM THE
MOTIVATING FORCE OF OUR
CONVERSION FROM QUARTERS TWO
SEMESTERS WHICH BECAME OFFICIAL.
IN FALL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AND
WHILE WE'RE ON PACE TO REACH
OUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOALS
OUR OBJECTIVE FOR OUT FOR YOUR
GRADUATION RATE IS COMPLICATED
BY THE NUMBER OF PROGRAMS ON
OUR CAMPUS PARTICULARLY IN
ENGINEERING THAT REQUIRE FIVE
YEARS OF STUDY BY DESIGN. THESE
CHALLENGES ARE SERIOUS BUT AS
YOU WILL HEAR FROM OUR
PANELISTS TODAY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A FIRM FOUNDATION
FOCUSED ON STUDENT SUCCESS AND
BASIC NEEDS THAT UNDERLINED THE
ENTIRE C. ISSUES SYSTEMS FOCUS
ON THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND THAT
FOCUS WILL PROPEL US TO OUR
GOALS THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING
HERE CALIFORNICA MONA AND THE
SUPPORTING THE C. ISSUES
SYSTEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARTICLE IN FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR GRACIOUS WELCOME TO US
HERE ON THE CAMPUS TO LOOK FOR
TO TALKING WITH YOUR STAFF
THROUGHOUT THE MORNING HERE
NINE DIGGING DOWN A LITTLE BIT
MORE EACH OF THESE AREAS WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE GREAT
PROGRESS YOU'RE MAKING HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO WE HAVE
ON THE SCHEDULE DOCTOR CECILIA
SINCE IAGO GONZALEZ BUT- LIFE
KIND OF GETS IN THE WAY
SOMETIMES AND AS I UNDERSTAND
IT. SHE'S IN THE HOSPITAL
GIVING BIRTH. I'M HOPING THAT
WATCHING THIS LIVE STREAM. SO
DOCTORS IN CHICAGO GONZALES WHO
WISH YOU WELL. NOW THE BABY WAS
BORN THAN THAT WHAT WHERE IS
SHE. THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S A
POINT IN THE DIRECTION NOT.
MORE THAN THAT EXCEPT THAT WE
WISH YOU WELL AND THEN THE
YOUNG STERN AND THE FAMILY SO
BUT WE DO HAVE A FANTASTIC
SUBSTITUTE I UNDERSTAND DOCTOR
SEPT THAT AS GOOD DOLLERY BY
PRONOUNCE THAT RIGHT IS HERE IS
THE ASSOCIATE PROVOST FOR
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS HERE AT THE
CAMPUS. PRIOR TO YOUR ROLES IN
THIS ROLE AS I UNDERSTAND IT
YOU SERVICE HERE THE ACADEMIC
SENATE THEY WERE A DEPARTMENT
CHAIR IN BIOLOGICAL SCIENCES
YOU SEE BOTH YOUR BACHELOR'S
AND MASTER'S HERE CAL POLY
POMONA IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S YES
LOCAL LOCAL GUY MAKES GOOD YOU
GOT A PHD IN AND PHYSIOLOGY.
FROM UCLA BECAUSE THAT WAS A
BREAK DOWN THERE. THIS IS THE
LA BREAKDOWN. IT'S OKAY WE
WE'VE WE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE. AND WE LOOK FOR IS YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING CENTERS
GLAZER CENTER CHANG AND SENATOR
ROTH AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
OF OUR STUDENTS SUCCESS
STRATEGIES TODAY THIS MORNING.
AT CAL POLY POMONA WE BELIEVE
IN THE SHARED INSTITUTIONAL AND
CROSS DIVISIONAL GOAL OF
STUDENT SUCCESS IN OUR AS OUR
PRESIDENT MENTIONED. WE
REFERRED TO IT AS ONE TEAM ONE
GOAL STUDENT SUCCESS. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A COMPREHENSIVE AND
INTEGRATED FRAMEWORK FOR
STUDENT SUCCESS WHICH ALIGNS
BOTH WITH THIS YES YOU
GRADUATION INITIATIVE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AND OUR CAMPUS
STRATEGIC PLAN TO PROVIDE A
HOLISTIC SUPPORT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THE INTEGRATED MODEL
WHICH AS THE PRESIDENT
MENTIONED YOU HAVE IN YOUR
PACKET AND ALSO SHOWN ON THE
SCREENS. REFLECTS OUR UNIQUE
INCLUSIVE POLYTECHNIC APPROACH.
I'D LIKE TO BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT
ONLY A FEW TARGETED STUDENT
SUCCESS REFUGEES THAT REFLECT
THIS AND A GREAT APPROACH.
FIRST IS DATA INFORMED HOLISTIC
ADVISING WE'VE TAKEN
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TO REPOSITION
RESOURCES REINVESTING ADVISING
A JOSH PROCESS SEASON POLICIES
AND USE TECHNOLOGY TO PROVIDE A
MORE DATA SUPPORTED. INTEGRATED
AND HOLISTIC SUPPORT. HOLISTIC
STUDENT ADVISING EXPERIENCE
WITH G. I. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
FINDING WE HIRED NINE NEW
ADVISERS EIGHT RETENTION AND
GRADUATION SPECIALIST ONE IN
EACH ACADEMIC COLLEGE. AND A
CENTRALIZED THE ADVISING
COORDINATOR TO COORDINATE WITH
CAMPUS PARTNERS ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AN EARLY
ALERT AND PREDICTIVE ANALYTICS
SYSTEM. THIS NEW ADVISING
TECHNOLOGY WHICH WE CALL C. PP
CONTACT. PROVIDES ADVISORS.
WITH ACTIONABLE DATA TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS IN JUST
EIGHT SHORT MONTHS WE'VE HAD
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
ADVISORS AND TUTORS UTILIZING
THIS NEW ADVISING PLATFORM
STUDENTS HAVE SCHEDULED OVER
THIRTY SIX THOUSAND ADVISING
APPOINTMENTS. AND OVER NINETY
FOUR HUNDRED TUTORING SESSIONS
THROUGH THESE INVESTMENTS WOULD
DECREASE THEIR ADVISER TO
STUDENT RATIO FROM ONE ADVISER
FOR EVERY. ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR
STUDENTS WHICH IS QUITE HIGH.
TWO ONE FOR EVERY NINE HUNDRED
AND- EIGHTY SEVEN STUDENTS WITH
CONTINUED FUNDING THE CAMPUS IS
WORKING TO REDUCE THE STUDENT
TO ADVISOR RATIO TO THE
RECOMMENDED NATIONAL STANDARD
OF ONE FOR EVERY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
REDUCTIONS IN ADVISER LOADS
MEAN MORE SUSTAINED AND
PERSONAL ATTENTION FOR STUDENTS
LEADING TO HIGHER RETENTION
RATES PARTICULARLY IN THE
STUDENTS FIRST TWO YEARS. NEXT
I'LL TALK ABOUT FINANCIAL WELL
BEING. WHILE MY COLLEAGUE WILL
ADDRESS THE BROAD SPECTRUM OF
STUDENT WELLBEING I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ALSO ADDRESSING FINANCIAL
WELLNESS 74% OF OUR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS RECEIVE
SOME FORM OF FINANCIAL AID. TO
BETTER SERVE THEM WITH
DEVELOPED AND IMPLEMENTED A
FINANCIAL WELLNESS PROGRAM THAT
TARGETS DIFFERENT STUDENT
POPULATIONS DURING DIFFERENT
STAGES OF THEIR ACADEMIC
JOURNEY WITH APPROPRIATE
FINANCIAL LITERACY INFORMATION
CAP HOLLY RAMONA HAS PARTNERED
WITH I CRACKED. TO BRING
STUDENTS AND PARENTS OF
FINANCIAL LITERACY AND WELLNESS
PLATFORM I GRAD IS AN ENGAGING
AND INTERACTIVE TOOL THAT HELPS
STUDENTS LEARN ABOUT FINANCIAL
WELLNESS AND PROVIDES USEFUL
INFORMATION ON AN ARRAY OF
PERSONAL FINANCE TOPICS. NEXT
I'LL TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROMISE PLEDGE PROGRAMS
KAPALI POMONA WAS A PIONEER IN
THE CSU AS ONE OF THE FIRST
CAMPUSES TO LAUNCH A GRADUATION
PLEDGE PROGRAM WHICH PREDATES
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE PLEDGE
PROGRAM. AT THE PINNACLE OF
KAPALI POMONA'S PLEDGE PROGRAM
WE SERVED OVER ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
OUR HOMEGROWN PLEDGE INITIATIVE
HAS SET A GOOD FOUNDATION TO
FULLY IMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA
PROMISE. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WE BEGAN A PHASED
IMPLEMENTATION OF CALIFORNIA
PROMISE WITH TWO ACADEMIC
PROGRAMS FOR FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN AND ALL ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER OR AT T.
PROGRAMS FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
OPEN CALIFORNIA PROMISE TO
SEVERAL MORE MAJORS FOR FIRST
TIME FRESHMEN. THIS YEAR WE'VE
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE ALL MAJORS
FOR FIRST TIME FRESHMEN EXCEPT
FOR ARCHITECTURE WHICH BY
DESIGN IS A FIVE YEAR PROGRAM.
THIS YEAR WE'VE HAD OVER THREE
HUNDRED STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED
ALL OF THE NECESSARY STEPS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM
WHICH INCLUDES ENROLLING IN
FIFTEEN UNITS AND THEIR FIRST
TERM TO REACH THEIR THIRTY
UNITS BY THE END OF THE SUMMER.
AND MEETING WITH AN ADVISER TO
DEVELOP AN INDIVIDUALIZED ACTOR
THE ACADEMIC PLAN. GIVEN THAT
THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM
FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON SERVING
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
STUDENTS FROM SCHOOLS WITH LOW
COLLEGE ATTENDANCE RATES. AND
FROM SCHOOLS THAT SERVE MANY
LOW INCOME STUDENTS WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR OUTREACH
STRATEGIES ARE RESPONSIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF THE STUDENTS. AND
THAT WE DO OUR BEST TO ENSURE
THAT WE UTILIZE INNOVATIVE
STRATEGIES TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA PROMISE. OUR GOAL IS
TO CONTINUE INCREASING NUMBER
OF ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA PROMISED
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
PROGRAM. NEXT I'LL TALK ABOUT
THE AVERAGING AT LOW THAT THE
STUDENTS STEAK AND OUR TAKE
THIRTY CAMPAIGN INITIATIVE. IN
ORDER TO STAY ON TRACK FOR
FRESHMEN FOR YOUR GRADUATION
AND TRANSFER TO YOUR GRADUATION
STUDENTS NEED TO TAKE AN
AVERAGE OF FIFTY UNITS OF TERM.
I KAPALI POMONA WE LAUNCHED A
TAKE THIRTY CAMPAIGN. AN EFFORT
WHICH IS YIELDING VERY
PROMISING RESULTS IN THE FALL
OF TWENTY SIXTEEN TERM WHEN WE
WERE STILL ON THE QUARTER
CALENDAR. ONLY 22% OF INCOMING
FRESHMEN STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
FIFTEEN OR MORE UNITS. SO ARE
TAKE THIRTY CAMPAIGN WE'VE SEEN
A DRAMATIC INCREASE IN THE
PERCENTAGE OF INCOMING FRESHMEN
STUDENTS AND ROLLED IN FIFTEEN
OR MORE UNITS WILL FALL TWENTY
NINETEEN TURN. TO AN ALL TIME
HIGH OF 61% NEXT I'LL TALK
ABOUT STUDENT ENGAGEMENT
SUPPORTED AND ENHANCED BY
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE OR A I.
I'D LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT OUR
EFFORTS TO ENGAGE WITH NEW
STUDENTS USING AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE CHAT BOT. WHICH
MEETS STUDENTS WHERE THEY ARE
WHICH IS ON THE PHONES. WE CALL
THIS TOOL DAILY CHAT. BILL
RICHARD IS OUR HEY I TEXT
MESSAGING ROBOT AVAILABLE TO
INCOMING FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS STUDENTS CAN TEXT
BILLY QUESTIONS AND GET ANSWERS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN. WHEN BILLY
CANNOT PROVIDE AN APPROPRIATE
ANSWER A STAFF MEMBER STEPS IN
TO NOT ONLY ANSWER THE MORE
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS BUT ALSO A
DESIGN SAME TIME TO ADD TO BILL
IS. GROWING KNOWLEDGE BASE. WE
ALSO USE BILLY CHAT TO
COMMUNICATE WITH STUDENTS WHO
NEED NOTCHES TO ENROLL IN THE
UNIVERSITY SUCCESSFULLY. THESE
NOT JUST HAVE INCLUDED REMIND
STUDENTS ABOUT THE EARLY START
REQUIREMENT. REGISTERING FOR
INTONATION AND TRANSCRIPTS OF
MISSION. WE INITIALLY
COMMUNICATED WITH EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED NEW STUDENTS BILLY
CENTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MESSAGES AND HAS
RECEIVED NEARLY EIGHTY THOUSAND
WITHIN THE FIRST COUPLE OF
MONTHS THIS IS AN IMMEDIATE
SAVINGS OF NEARLY ONE THOUSAND
AND THREE HUNDRED STAFF HOURS.
WHO IN TURN CAN DIRECTOR FOCUS
ON HI TOUCH ADVISING CASES.
WHERE CAMPUS WITH A HIGH NUMBER
OF FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
AND BAILEY IS CRITICAL IN
HELPING THE STUDENTS TRANSITION
INTO UNIVERSITY LIFE. NEXT I'D
LIKE TO TALK ABOUT ELIMINATE
BARRIERS TO GRADUATION. TO
ASSIST STUDENTS AT THE END OF
THE ACADEMIC JOURNEY KAPALI
POMONA LAUNCHED A SUMMER
COMPLETION INITIATIVE AND I
MIGHT ADD USING PRIVATE
FOUNDATION DOLLARS TO ASSIST
STUDENTS WITH COMPLETING THEIR
DEGREE DURING THE SUMMER TERM
INSTEAD OF WAITING UNTIL THE
FALL TERM. IN SUMMER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CAL POLY POMONA OFFERS
SUMMER COMPLETION GRANTS TO
STUDENTS WHO WERE LESS THAN
EIGHT UNITS 2 DEGREES. THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
STUDENTS OR WERE GIVEN THE
GRANTS AND 93% WHICH IS A VERY
HIGH SUCCESS RATE 93% COMPLETED
THE DEGREE DURING THAT SUMMER.
FROM THE STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE
THIS IS AN IMMEDIATE SAVINGS OF
NEARLY THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND A LONGER TERM SAVINGS OF
NEARLY THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THIS EFFORT SUPPORTED
OUR DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION
REGARDLESS OF FINANCIAL NEED.
ARE THE STUDENTS WHO COMPLETED
THE DE QUEEN IN THE SUMMER OF
62% OR PAL ELIGIBLE 51% WERE
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS AND 62% WERE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS. WE
RECENTLY COMPLETED YOUR TWO OF
THE SUMMER COMPLETION
INITIATIVE AND ARE WAITING FOR
THE FINAL GRADUATION RESULTS TO
COME IN. FINALLY I'D LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
PROGRESS. THE STRATEGIES IS
HIGHLIGHTED ARE BUT A FEW OF
OUR INSTITUTIONAL EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE RETENTION INCREASE
GRADUATION RATES FOR BOTH
FRESHMAN AND TRANSFERS AND
CLOSE EQUITY GAPS. THE C. AS
YOUR GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE PROVIDES US
WITH CLEAR METRICS AND SYSTEM
SUPPORT TO ACHIEVE THESE
AMBITIOUS GOALS. OUR CAMPUS HAS
MADE STEADY PROGRESS IN BOTH
INCREASING FRESHMAN ENTRANCE
GRADUATION RATES AND DECREASING
EQUITY GAPS. AS YOU CAN SEE IN
THE HAND OUT TABLE THAT IS
PROVIDED TO YOU AND ALSO CAN BE
SEEN ON THE SCREENS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE WERE ONE OF ONLY
TWO CAMPUSES AMONG THE TWENTY
THREE CSU CAMPUSES. TO MAKE
PROGRESS ON ALL SIX METRICS.
CONTINUED SUPPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE SYSTEM
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
REACH OUR GOALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTORATE
IT'S A GREAT GREAT PRESENTATION
AND- YOU KNOW WHEN I LOOKED
AROUND THE- THE C. S. U. FOR
EXAMPLES OF GREAT LEADERSHIP IN
THE AREA OF GRADUATION RATES.
IT WAS ONE OF TWO CAMPUSES THAT
I FOCUSED ON BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT YOU DID AND YOU CALL
THAT YOU WERE A PIONEER AND IT
WAS TRUE. THAT SIDE YOUR
GRADUATION PLEDGE THAT YOU
BEGAN ON OFFER THAT'S TWO
THOUSAND. NINETEEN NINETY NINE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE YEAH. AND
IT WAS IT WAS BOTH OF POMONA
SANDRA DINO WITH THE TWO
LEADERS ON THIS. AND PART OF
CREATING THE CALIFORNIA PROMISE
PROGRAM WAS TO USE YOUR
CAMPUSES GREAT LEADERSHIP AND
SUCCESS AND PUTTING THAT
LEGISLATION FORWARD. AND I
THINK AS YOU MENTIONED AT THAT
AT ONE TIME HE HAD A THOUSAND
KIDS IN THAT PROGRAM. AND I
GUESS THE THING THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT SURPRISED ME ABOUT
POMONA ONE IS THAT. IS THAT THE
GOALS PRETTY LOW. I KNOW YOU'VE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS BUT IF YOU
LOOK AT IT FROM A STATEWIDE
BASIS. OTHER MODEST IN AND OUT
WHAT YOU WANT TO ACCOMPLISH I
THINK GIVEN THE PROGRESS YOU'VE
MADE SO FAR WHICH HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS PSYCH. THE CEILINGS
THAT YOU HAD A STEREO THAT THE
GOALS THAT YOU ESTABLISH TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. I'M HOPING YOU
GUYS BLOW THROUGH THAT. BY FAR
I REALLY THINK YOU CAN. AND I
HOPE THAT IT MAYBE ALLOWS YOU
TO DO A RE ASSESSMENT OF WHAT
YOUR POTENTIAL REALLY IS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S MUCH
GREATER THAN A- 38% FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE. PROFESSIONAL I.
IS EVEN THOSE NUMBERS. THE
UNFORTUNATE PART THERE'S GROWTH
AND THEN THERE'S THE NUMBERS.
AND MAYBE YOU CAN SPEAK TO. NO.
ANP TALK ABOUT BEING DATA
DRIVEN. THOUSANDS OF KIDS ARE
STILL DROPPING OUT OF THIS
UNIVERSITY AND MANY OTHERS
AROUND THE STATE. DO YOU DO ANY
KIND OF SYSTEMATIC SURVEY OF
THOSE STUDENTS TO FIND OUT WHY.
WE HAVE THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION WE HAVE A
LOT OF STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
OUR RETENTION RATES. WE HAVE
WERE USING DATA ANALYTICS TO
UNDERSTAND WHY STUDENTS AREN'T
RETURNING SO FOR EXAMPLE. AS AN
EXAMPLE OF AND GETTING READY
FOR THE SPRING TERM. WE HAVE
DATA THAT WE CAN SEE WHO WERE
THE STUDENTS WHO WERE HERE IN
THE FALL BUT HAVE NOT YET
ENROLLED FOR THE SPRING TERM.
WE HAVE TARGETED STRATEGIES TO
TARGET THOSE STUDENTS TO
UNDERSTAND WHY THEY ARE NOT
RETURNING WHAT IS THE REASON IS
IT IS IT A FINANCIAL REASON OR
DO OTHER REASONS. AS FAR AS A
SERVICE SURVEY I CAN. DEFER TO
MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK OF SURVEYS.
ANYBODY HAVE ANY INSIGHT ABOUT
DAY ACTUALLY TALKING TO
STUDENTS WHO HAVE DRAWN DOWN.
LET ME JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT ATKINS I
APPRECIATE IN YOUR METRICS HERE
WE TALK ABOUT DATA DRIVEN
DECISION MAKING. AND THERE'S
LOTS OF WAYS TO APPLY THAT BOTH
INTO MAKING CLASSES AVAILABLE
IF STUDENTS WANT TO TAKE. IT'S
ALSO TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THOSE BARRIERS ARE THAT MADE
THEM SAY THEY THEY COULD
CONTINUE CERTAINLY FINANCIAL
ISSUES WILL ALWAYS BE IN PLAY.
BUT WE HEAR A LOT FROM STUDENTS
TO THAT THEY COULDN'T GET THEIR
CLASSES THEY COULDN'T GET THERE
WAS THERE WAS A PREREQUISITE
REQUIRED AND IT WASN'T
AVAILABLE. NOW IS GONNA SET
THEM BACK FOR A SEMESTER OR
YEAR WITH AT GREAT COST AND
EXPENSE. I THINK WE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT STARTLING
NUMBER THAT WE DON'T LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT MUCH BUT IT'S TRUE.
IT'S NOT JUST HUNDREDS IT'S
TENS OF THOUSANDS EVERY YEAR
STATEWIDE DROPOUT. AND IT BE
GOOD FOR IF WE HAD THE DATA TO
CAN UNDERSTAND THAT. I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE AND- GREAT PHRASE
HERE TAKE THIRTY CAMPAIGN AND
THAT THE NUMBERS THAT YOU HAVE
MOVED ON FRESHMAN IS X.
EXTRAORDINARY. EXTRAORDINARY
AND I'D LOVE TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
THAT ADVERTISING THAT WENT INTO
THAT THE PROMOTION OF THAT
BECAUSE WHAT WHAT'S STUNNING
NUMBERS. THAT YOU SHARED WITH
US. TODAY GOING FROM 22%
FRESHMAN TAKING. 3261% THAT'S
INCREDIBLE. THE IF I MAY
SENATOR IF WITH RESPECT TO THE
CLASS SCHEDULE WE USE BOTH DATA
ANALYTICS AND ALSO INFORMATION
FROM ADVISERS TO STUDENTS
SENATE DEPARTMENTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THE CLASSES THAT THE
STUDENTS NEED ARE OFFERED IN
THE CLASS SCHEDULE WE HAVE.
WORKED VERY HARD WITH ALL OF
OUR DEPARTMENTS AND COLLEGES TO
INSURE THAT WE EXPANDED THE
TIMES THAT THE CLASSES ARE
OFFERED FROM EARLY IN THE
MORNING TO LATE IN THE EVENING.
EVEN ON THE WEEKENDS SO WE HAVE
MORE CLASSES EARLIER IN THE
MORNING WE HAVE MORE CLASSES
LATER IN THE EVENING SO MORE
MORE CLASSES. ON THE WEEKENDS.
TO ADDRESS THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. OUR AS I. HAS JUST
INITIATED A PROGRAM TO. TRY TO
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF NON
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS AS WELL
SO WE WILL PARTNER WITH THEM TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THOSE NEEDS
FOR CLASS. NOT A GREAT ANYWAYS
I CERTAINLY HERE THAT I HEARD
THIS MORNING. AND BY MEETING.
WITH SOME OF THE STUDENT
LEADERS AND LET ME JUST TODAY.
FINISH UP WITH THE- ONE MORE
OBSERVATION AND THEN ASK A
QUESTION. IN THE SUMMER
COMPLETION INITIATIVE IS
SOMETHING THAT I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO. TO
FIND AND TO HELP YOU MENTION
YOU GOT PRIVATE MONEY TO DO
THAT SO THAT'S A DOUBLE PRAISE
FOR. THAT ACCOMPLISHMENT I
THINK THAT. MANY OF US WITH
LOOK FOR WAYS TO TRY TO SUPPORT
THE SUMMER INITIATIVES WITH
FUNDING FROM THE STATE. AND I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION FIGURE OUT A WAY
TO DO THAT BECAUSE- TO TAKE
THOSE THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
SEVEN STUDENTS THERE WERE EIGHT
UNITS AWAY FROM A DEGREE AND WE
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE WITH NO
DEGREE DEGREE IT'S A MASSIVE
DIFFERENCE ECONOMICALLY. AND TO
BE ABLE TO GET THEM OVER THE
TOP WITH THAT SUMMER PROGRAM IS
INCREDIBLY. VALUABLE FOR THEM
AND FOR THE STATE AND I'D
CERTAINLY LIKE TO FIND A WAY TO
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS WITH PUBLIC
DOLLARS NOT JUST YOUR SUCCESS
IN RAISING. A PRIVATE DOLLARS
BUT MY POINT FINAL QUESTION AND
MAYBE THIS WILL CONTINUE. WITH
OTHER FOLKS THAT ARE GOING TO
TESTIFY. IS SHE IS IT IS THE
ISSUE OF THE PROMISE PROGRAM
THE COMMITMENT THE PLEDGE. IT'S
ONE THING TO SEE AN ENCOURAGING
AND ENCOURAGE MORE UNITS TO BE
TAKEN. IT'S ANOTHER THING TO
HAVE A COMMITMENT BETWEEN THE
INSTITUTION A STUDENT THAT SAYS
IF A STUDENT WANTS TO GET
THROUGH IN FOUR YEARS AND
MAINTAINS A C. AVERAGE OR C.
PLUS AVERAGE. AND TAKES THIRTY
UNITS THAT WE'RE GONNA
GUARANTEE THAT THEY CAN DO IT.
AND THAT'S THE ESSENCE OF THE
PROMISE PROGRAM IS A PLEDGE
FROM BOTH SIDES. AND IT IT DE
IT DOES CREATE PRESSURES ON THE
INSTITUTION. AND I KNOW THAT
IT'S SACKS STATED AT SAN JOSE
STATE WHEN THOSE G. THE
UNIVERSITY LEADERSHIP AGREED TO
PROMOTE THAT PROMISE PROGRAM
AND SAID THE KIDS YOU WANNA GET
OUT IN FOUR YEARS. YOU MAKE
THESE COMMITMENTS WE MAKE THESE
AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT TO A
TOGETHER THAT'S IT THAT'S AN
INCREDIBLE POWERFUL PARTNERSHIP.
GOING FORWARD AND I I'M
SURPRISED THAT THAT. THAT HE
WOULD POMONA TAKES AN X. SIX OR
SEVEN MOUSE CLICKS. ON IT. ON
YOUR WEBSITE TO FIND ANYTHING
ABOUT YOUR PHOENICIAN FOR YOUR
CALIFORNIA PROMISE PROGRAM.
ACTUAL SCREEN SHOTS I'M GOING
TO THE POMONA WEBSITE TRY TO
FIND INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AND WE CAN REVIEW THAT.
BUT I'M I'M JUST WONDERING WHY
YOU'RE NOT PUTTING UP A
STRONGER EFFORT INTO INTO AT
THE PROMISE PROGRAM GETTING THE
STUDENTS TO COMMIT TO IT AND
HAVING YOU MAKE A SIMILAR
COMMITMENT THAT THE NUMBERS OF
THREE HUNDRED. EVEN YOUR
HISTORICAL NUMBERS WE HAD A
THOUSAND IN IT TEN YEARS AGO.
TO SEE IT SOLO WAS SURPRISING
TO ME. THANK YOU SENATOR THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND
TO THIS QUESTION. I I'D LIKE TO
START BY SAYING THAT ABSOLUTELY
WHEN WE NEED TO DO A LOT BETTER
OUR WE ARE IMPLEMENTED
CALIFORNIA PROMISED LAST YEAR
WE STARTED. WITH A SMALL NUMBER
THIS YEAR WE'VE GROWN TO
PROGRAM QUITE A BIT WE HAVE.
JUST ABOUT DOWN THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY STUDENTS AT THE
MOMENT ABOUT TWO THIRDS ARE
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN ABOUT ONE
THIRD I TRANSFER STUDENTS. WE
RECOGNIZE WE NEED TO HAVE A
MUCH GREATER COMMITMENT TO
RECRUITING THE STUDENTS FOR ON
CALIFORNIA PROMISE MAKING SHORT
AT. THE MOMENT THEY COMMIT TO
COMING TO KAPALI POMONA. THAT
WE REACH OUT AND WE ENJOYED
THAT. THAT THE THEY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN THE
PROGRAM. A SHARP PIPELINES NEED
TO BE MUCH STRONGER THOSE FOUR
AND COMING FIRST TIME FRESHMEN
STUDENTS BUT ALSO TRANSFER
STUDENTS. THOSE PIPELINES NEED
TO ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO JOIN
THE PROGRAM BUT ALSO THE
INVITATION THAT THE STUDENTS
GET ONCE THEY ARE ON CAMPUS WE
NEED TO DO A MUCH BETTER JOB TO
IMPROVE THOSE NUMBERS. WE WERE
JUST AWARDED A M. APART A TITLE
FIVE GRAND AND ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT COMPONENTS OF THAT
WENT TO JUST TO DO PRECISELY
THAT TO IMPROVE OUR PIPELINE
PROGRAMS. GREAT THAT'S GREAT TO
HEAR AND I LOOK FORWARD IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. AND WE WANT TO HELP
THE HELP YOU TO AND THE FOUR TO
WORKING ON THAT. YES ALSO JUST
RESPOND AS YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
THE PROMISED. LAND IN FACT. THE
UNDERLYING PHILOSOPHY AND THE
VALUE OF THE PROMISE PROGRAM.
FROM CAL POLY POMONA'S
PERSPECTIVE IS WHAT ALSO G. I.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS ABOUT.
BECAUSE WE WHILE WE CERTAINLY
WILL. CONTINUE TO BE
INTENTIONAL BUT THOSE STUDENTS.
WHO CAN AND WILL MAKE THAT.
DEFINITIVE PLEDGE WHAT WE FOUND
AS WE LOOK TO SOME OF THE DATA
FOR THE STUDENTS WHO STARTED
AND CONTINUE THE PROGRAM. IS IT
MORE OFTEN THEY CHANGED MAJORS.
THEY ENDED UP DECIDING FOR.
OFTEN TIMES FINANCIAL REASONS
THAT THEY NEEDED TO BOTH WORK
PART TIME AND GO TO SCHOOL. AND
SO WHAT THE LIST THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE BUT ALSO. THE BORDER.
GRADUATION INITIATIVE THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT HAS
ALLOWED THE CAMPUSES TO DEVELOP
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. I THINK
THAT WHAT WE HAVE HAVE SHOWN.
IS THAT THE ABILITY TO TRACK
STUDENTS THE ABILITY TO FOLLOW
WHAT THE STUDENTS. JUST THE
BILLY CHAT. ALONE HAS SHOWN.
THAT THE FUNDING THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THE STATE. HAS
BEEN THE SENSUAL. TO CREATE AN
INSTITUTIONAL CULTURAL SHIFT.
AND WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS THE-
DEVELOPMENT OF THESE ELEMENTS
THAT WE THINK ARE CRITICAL AND
THE NEED TO WORK. TOGETHER AND
SO WHETHER IT'S THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE WOULD JUST SAID THERE'S
REALLY BEEN A FOUNDATION. FOR
OUR THINKING HERE AT CAL POLY
POMONA ABOUT HOW WE STRUCTURE.
THE BROADER NETWORK OF. OF
SERVICES AND ACTIVITIES. SO
THAT YOU WILL SEE ARE THE. KIND
OF PROGRESS. YOU MADE MENTION
IN TERMS OF THESE NUMBERS DID
THE GOALS THAT WERE SET WE
RECOGNIZE TO AND I'M AND AS THE
CHANCES OFFICE IS WORKING WITH
THE VARIOUS CAMPUSES ALSO
LOOKING IF YOU WILL AT. THE
ADVISER TO STUDENT RATIO
LOOKING OUT WHAT WILL IT HEY.
IT THEN ALLOWED US TO STEP BACK
AND THINK IN A MUCH MORE
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK MANNER AS
TO HOW WE WERE GOING TO
OPERATIONALIZE AND IMPLEMENT.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE A PATH
FORWARD YOU WILL SEE THE
CAMPUSES GOING ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT THOSE THOSE EXPECTATIONS
ARE AND SO WE'RE VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE TRAJECTORY THAT WE ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR REID JUST ONE COMMENT I
HAPPEN TO BELIEVE AND I. THINK
YOU PROBABLY AGREE THAT.
EFFECTIVE COUNSELING IS FAIRLY
KEY TO ATTEND THE GRADUATION.
SO AS WE MOVE INTO THE NEXT
BUDGET CYCLE WHAT I HOPE AND
TALKING TO PEOPLE WHO I HOPE
FOR LISTENING TO THIS. THE FROM
AN INSTITUTIONAL STANDPOINT WE
SEE SOME NUMBER APPEAR THAT TO
TELLS US WHAT EXACTLY WE NEED
TO DO IN ORDER TO FUND. TO GET
YOU FROM ONE TO NINE HUNDRED OR
ONE TO A THOUSAND DOWN ON
CLOSER TO ONE TO FIVE HUNDRED.
BECAUSE I THINK EFFECTIVE
COUNSELING. TALKING TO STUDENTS
ABOUT WHAT THEY NEED TO TAKE
WHAT THEY SHOULDN'T WASTE THEIR
TIME TAKING WILL HELP US MOVE
PEOPLE THROUGH THE PIPELINE A
LITTLE FASTER. WITH THE KIND OF
DEGREE THAT'S GOING TO PRODUCE
A GOOD. GOOD PAYING JOB
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION
INSTITUTIONAL SATISFACTION IT'S
A WIN WIN FOR EVERYBODY SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT NUMBER WHEN WE
START THE BUDGET PROCESS THIS
NEXT YEAR THANK YOU FOR THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I ALSO WOULD
JUST JUST LIKE TO ADD THAT.
WHAT WE'VE ALSO RECOGNIZE AND
THEN THE BEAUTY. OF THE
GRADUATION NISH IT HAS BEEN
THAT THE CAMPUSES. I'VE BEEN
ALLOWED TO INDIVIDUALIZE THEIR
NEEDS BECAUSE FOR SOME CAMPUSES
THAT. THAT COUNSELOR RATIO IS
LOWER FOR KAPLAN MONNING GETS
HIGHER AND SO WHAT THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE HAS
REALLY. IN COVERAGE IS RATHER
THAN A COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH
TO THE WAY WE WOULD. MEET OUR
GOALS AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS SUCCEED IS IT THE
CAMPUSES ARE ABLE TO PUT THE
DOLLARS BASED ON FORD THERE IS
THE GREATEST NEED AND SO YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. ACCOUNT POLY
POMONA IT WAS LOOKING AT
ADVISORS AND CHANGING THAT
RATIO FOR ANOTHER CAMPUS. THAT
ADVISING SYSTEM IS ALREADY BEEN
IN PLACE AND SO THEIR DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO GO TO AREAS THAT
THEY HAVE THAT OUR GREATEST
NEED SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE SUPPORT
FOR THE GRADUATION ISSUE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WELL WE OBVIOUSLY
NEED TO GET YOU MORE MONEY WELL
YOU KNOW. WHAT MONA WILL NEVER
TURN DOWN. BUT I THINK I THINK
IT YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK AT AND
I'M AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW I'M ON
THE FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION
AND WHAT WE RECOGNIZE IS THAT
IS A C. ISSUE SYSTEM OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA
BEING FUELED BY THE STUDENTS
INTO THAT INTO THAT MAINSTREAM
THAT THE ENTIRE. TWENTY THREE
CAMPUS SYSTEM IS CAN IS NEEDING
TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THE WAYS
IN WHICH WE CAN MOST
APPROPRIATELY. MEET THE NEEDS
OF OUR REGION AND OF OUR LOCAL
LOCAL AREA SO THIS I THINK AS
I'M BUT TALK WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN OTHER STATES THIS
HAS BEEN. THE MOST INNOVATIVE
AND I THINK IMPACTFUL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OF THE SUPPORT OF
THE G. I. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IN
HIGHER EDUCATION WELL I THINK
MAYBE WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS
LOOK AT. THE BUDGET BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE BUDGET TO
ZERO SUM GAME SO WHICH IS VERY
DIFFICULT IT HAS TO BALANCE AND
WE DON'T PRINT MONEY. BUT
PERHAPS WHAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
IS DIRECTING A LITTLE BIT MORE
MONEY. AT THE INSTITUTION
LITTLE THE BILL WOULD ALLOW THE
CHANCELLOR TO FOR COUNSELING
PURPOSES THAT WILL ALLOW THE
CHANCELLOR TO REDIRECT MONEY.
TO THOSE CAMPUSES IN THE
ADDITIONAL COUNSELING RESOURCES
FOR WHATEVER REASON SO ANYWAY
I'M NOT GOING TO BELABOR THIS
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING A
CONVERSATION. JANET IT'S A IT'S
A GOOD POINT AND I JUST TO
CLARIFY YOUR TIME ACADEMIC
COUNSELOR WE'RE GOING TO DEAL
WITH SOME OTHER COUNSELING
ISSUES INVOLVED ACADEMIC JOBS
AND THE PHONE RANG. RIGHT PROS
ALTHOUGH I THINK WHEN YOU HEAR
ABOUT THE OTHER TYPES OF
COUNSELING I THINK HOPEFULLY
YOU'RE. THE SENATE WILL
CONTINUE AND THAT DIRECTION AS
WELL. YES SIR. QUICKLY OUR
RESPONSE THANK YOU CENTER ROTH
FOR ASKING A QUESTION UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF PRESIDENT GOALIE
AND- PROVOST ALTHOUGH THE
CAMPUS HAS ENGAGED IN A MULTI
YEAR. ADVISER ON HIRING PLANNED
TO DETERMINE WHAT IT TAKES TO
BRING THE NUMBERS THE
RECOMMENDED NUMBER OF. DODD ONE
ADVISER FOR EVERY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS. WITH THE COST
STRUCTURE THAT IS REQUIRED TO
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL. THANK YOU
SOPHIA AND HERE'S A DE DATA
POINT. TAKE IT FOR WHAT IT'S
WORTH IT'S A COUPLE YEARS OLD
BUT WHEN THE C. S. YOU LOOKED
AT. ALL THOSE WHO HAD GRADUATED
THEY'VE GOT THEIR DEGREE. THE
AVERAGE. GRADUATE HAS TAKEN
ALMOST FIFTEEN UNITS EXTRA.
THAN THEY NEEDED TO GET THEIR
DEGREE NOW. PART OF THAT'S THAT
TO WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
EARLIER PEOPLE CAN CHANGE
MAJORS THAT CAN CHANGE YOUR
MIND THEY CAN JUST. C. CLASS
THEY WANTED TAKEN. TAKE IT.
NOBODY CAN RESTRICT THAT. BUT
IT DOES ALSO POTENTIALLY SPEAK
TO. THE BENEFITS THAT WOULD
COME FROM THAT ENHANCED
ACADEMIC ADVISING AND I KNOW
THE TOOLS OF WITH THE ADVENT
IMPROVED IN TERMS OF. PATHWAYS
FOR STUDENTS IN ONLINE AND
THEIR RATE REGISTRATION FOR
CLASSES AND ALL THE REST TO.
SEE WHETHER SOMETHING IS
APPLICABLE TO THEIR DEGREE OR
NOT AND THEY'RE GONNA MAKE THE
CHOICE TO WANNA MAKE BUT AT
LEAST THEY- WON'T DO IT
THINKING THAT HELP SENATE AND
IT REALLY DOESN'T. AND WE HAVE
A- A COHORT OF GRADUATES THAT
HAVE TAKEN A FULL EXERCER
MASTERED THAT'S MORE THAN
NECESSARY YOU HAVE TO GO AND
EXAMINE THAT AND- AND THAT DATA
WILL. HELP FURTHER. ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT I WANT TO CONTINUE ON
WITH ARE WONDERFUL. EXPERTS
THAT WE HAVE HERE DOCTOR LEVINE
IS A LIVING AIRLINE. LEVINE I
DID GET IT RIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. THE DEAN AND
PROFESSOR OF MUSIC HERE AT
POMONA. AND YOU. SHARE SOME OF
YOUR OWN. EXPERTISE OF FACULTY
PERSPECTIVE AND OTHERS WE
WELCOME YOU AND WE LOOK FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. SO MUCH GOOD
MORNING SENATORS I AM IRIS
LEVIN THE DEAN OF THE COLLEGE
OF LETTERS ARTS AND SOCIAL
SCIENCES AS YOU JUST HEARD. AND
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO TALK ABOUT
HOW OUR COLLEGE PLAYS A ROLE IN
THE INTEGRATED MODEL. OF
STUDENT SUCCESS THROUGH
HOLISTIC ADVISING AND COACHING.
OUR COLLEGE PROMOTES HOLISTIC
ADVISING FOR STUDENTS AND HIS
INITIATE IT INITIATED A PILOT
PROGRAM OF COACHING STUDENTS
CALLED FIRST CLASS COACHING
WITH CLASS BEING THE ACRONYM
FOR THE COLLEGE OF LETTERS ARTS
AND SOCIAL SCIENCES. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THE
WELL BEING AN EDUCATIONAL
ASPIRATIONS FOR OUR STUDENTS
FOR WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY SHAPE
STUDENTS FUTURE IN SUPPORT OF A
LIFETIME OF ACHIEVEMENT. OUR
FACULTY ARE ENGAGED IN BOTH THE
ADVISING AND COACHING MODELS
AND WE HAVE A ROBUST FACULTY
LED STUDENT SUCCESS COMMITTEE
THAT ARE CHAMPIONS FOR OUR
COLLEGE INITIATIVES. OUR
COLLEGE HOUSES APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED STUDENTS IN
FIFTEEN DIFFERENT PROGRAMS OF
STUDY AND 68% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
MINORITIES PRIMARILY LET NECKS
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN. OUR
ADVISING MODEL IS A HOLISTIC
TEAM APPROACH CONSISTING OF
STAFF ADVISORS IN OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS CENTER. FACULTY
ADVISORS IN EACH OF OUR LEVIN
DEPARTMENTS OUR FACULTY STUDENT
SUCCESS COMMITTEE. OUR PEER
MENTORS AND THE TWENTY ONE
COACHES INVOLVED IN FIRST CLASS
COACHING. IN OUR STUDENT
SUCCESS CENTER WE HAVE FOUR
STAFF ADVISORS ONE OF WHOM IS A
RETENTION AND GRADUATION
SPECIALIST. LITTLE CHANGE IN
OUR ADVISING PROCESS IS THE
MOVE FROM PASSIVE ADVISING
WAITING FOR STUDENTS TO COME TO
SEE US TO ACTIVE ADVISING
SCHEDULING APPOINTMENTS WITH
STUDENTS HOLDING WORKSHOPS ON
STUDY SKILLS AND STRESS
MANAGEMENT. PROVIDING ADVISING
CHECKLIST FOR FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN CONNECTING STUDENTS
WITH OUR CAREER CENTER AND
UTILIZING A ROBUST APPROACH TO
COMMUNICATING VIA SOCIAL MEDIA
AND DIGITAL DISPLAYS THROUGHOUT
OUR BUILDINGS. OUR FIRST CLASS
COACHING PROGRAM IS A THREE
YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IN
COLLABORATION WITH STUDENT
AFFAIRS. THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES
AN ACADEMIC ADVISING COACH TO
ALL FIRST TIME FRESHMEN UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITIES AND
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS.
THESE COACHES ARE EXISTING
STAFF AND FACULTY WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN A COMPREHENSIVE
TRAINING OF THIS COACHING
METHODOLOGY. THIS TRAINING WAS
SUPPORTED BY PRIVATE FUNDING.
OUR STAFF COACHES NOW HAVE
THESE RESPONSIBILITIES WRITTEN
INTO THEIR CURRENT JOB
DESCRIPTIONS AND FACULTY
COACHES HAVE RECEIVED RELEASE
TIME FROM TEACHING TO SUPPORT
THEIR EFFORTS IN COACHING. IN
YEAR ONE WE HAD FIFTEEN COACHES
WORKING WITH OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY STUDENTS. THIS YEAR YEAR
TWO WE HAVE TWENTY ONE COACHES
WORKING WITH JUST ABOUT THAT
SAME NUMBER OF STUDENTS.
COACHES HAVE A VARIETY OF
TOPICS THAT THEY DISCUSS WITH
STUDENTS RANGING FROM ACADEMICS
AND CAREER TO KEEPING
COMMITMENTS HEALTH FINANCES AND
GRADUATION HOPES. YOU CAN SEE
THE PERCENTAGES IN THE PIE
CHART WHICH IS ON THE SCREEN
AND I BELIEVE IN YOUR HANDOUT
AS WELL. AS WE ARE NOW IN THE
SECOND YEAR OF THIS OF THIS
PROGRAM WE HAVE PRELIMINARY
DATA ON FALL TO FALL RETENTION
RATES OF YOU ARE M. STUDENTS
AND FIRST GENERATION STONES IN
THIS COACHING PILOT. FROM THIS
LAST YEAR AND THE PRELIMINARY
RESULTS ARE VERY PROMISING. FOR
FIRST YEAR UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITY STUDENTS IN CLASS WE
HAD A ONE YEAR INCREASE IN
RETENTION OF SIX POINT 5% FOR
EIGHTY THREE POINT 2% TO EIGHTY
NINE POINT 7% RETENTION. AND
FOR FIRST YEAR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS WE HAD A ONE YEAR
INCREASE IN RETENTION OF SIX
POINT 8% FROM EIGHTY TWO POINT
9% TO EIGHTY NINE POINT 7%
FOLLOWING YOUR ONE WE ALSO
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF THOSE
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN THE FIRST
CLASS COACHING PROGRAM. SOME OF
THE UNSOLICITED QUOTES FROM
STUDENTS ARE ON THIS NEXT SLIDE
AND AGAIN IN YOUR HANDOUT. ON
ITS FACE IT SEEMS RATHER
UNNECESSARY BUT AS YOU MEET
WITH YOUR COACH IT'S NICE TO
KNOW THAT SOMEONE AT THE
UNIVERSITY IS GENUINELY
INTERESTED IN YOU AS A PERSON.
AND CARES ABOUT YOU DOING WELL
IN ALL ASPECTS OF YOUR LIFE.
AND FROM ANOTHER STUDENT. THE
PROGRAM ALLOWED ME TO HAVE
SOMEONE I COULD ALWAYS TALK TO
AND MAKE SURE THAT I STAYED ON
TRACK FOR MY FUTURE GOALS. IT
WAS VERY COOL TO BE INVOLVED IN
THIS AND IT WAS DEFINITELY
EFFECTIVE. WE ARE VERY PROUD OF
OUR EFFORTS WITH RESPECT TO
ADVISING AND COACHING. THANK
YOU FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT OUR
HOLISTIC APPROACH TO ADVISING
AND COACHING THANK YOU DOCTOR
LIVING WHAT A GREAT STORY THAT
YOU HAVE SHARED AND THE- NO I
USED TO OUTPLAY I'LL A FEW
YEARS AGO ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE I MADE A AN OBSERVATION
ABOUT. THE FRUSTRATION OF FIVE
STUDENTS IN OUR UNIVERSITIES
BEING TREATED LIKE A NUMBER.
NOT LIKE A PERSON. AND I HELD
UP A PIECE OF FRUIT AND SAID
THAT THERE ARE MORE TOUCHES TO
THIS PIECE OF FRUIT FROM
HARVESTING TO. BE PICKING UP IN
A GROCERY STORE MORE TOUCHES BY
PEOPLE. A PIECE OF FRUIT IN
THERE IS TO STUDENT IN MANY OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES. AND YOUR WORK
THAT YOU'RE SUCCESSFUL WORK IN
TRYING TO. BREAK THROUGH THAT
AND CREATE THAT PERSONAL
CONNECTION IS INCREDIBLY
IMPRESSIVE. AND IMPORTANCE AND
I KNOW WE HAVE REPRESENTS FROM
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HERE
TAKING NOTE ABOUT BEST
PRACTICES AND YOU'VE GIVEN A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF A- OF A
WONDERFUL BEST PRACTICE IN AND
CERTAINLY ASKING STAFF AND
FACULTY TO DO MORE. AND THAT'S
NOT EASY TO DO THEY HAVE A LOT
OF APPLICATIONS SO I APPRECIATE
THAT THAT REQUIRED THEM TO STEP
UP AND- IMPORTANT WAYS NOW HOPE
THEY FEEL THAT FILAMENT. AND
THE SUCCESS THAT YOU SHARE WITH
US TODAY THANK YOU. SENATE ROCK
MISTER CHAIR MA'AM I WAS JUST
CURIOUS ON THE PIE CHART. UNDER
DISCUSSIONS WITH COACHES
THERE'S A CATEGORY. OF HEALTH
SENATE INDICATES A PERCENT. HOW
DOES THAT. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAN PROVIDE ANY MORE DETAIL ON
THAT PARTICULAR CATEGORY AND
I'M CURIOUS AS TO HOW THAT
RELATES TO OUR EFFORTS WITH
RESPECT TO MENTAL HEALTH
CAMPUSES MENTAL HEALTH OF
STUDENTS AND OTHER RELATED
ISSUES. RIGHT I DON'T I CAN'T
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT THOSE
COMMENTS WERE WITH RESPECT TO
HEALTH BUT THE USER THESE
PERCENTAGES WERE BROUGHT TO US
FROM THE STUDENT SURVEYS SO
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO REPORTING
BACK THAT THEY TALKED WITH
THEIR COACHES ABOUT ISSUES OF
HEALTH AND WHEN THEY DO OUR
COACHES ARE TRAINED TO KNOW
WEIRD TO WALK THAT STUDENT OVER
TO WHETHER IT IS THE COUNSELING
CENTER OR WHETHER IT IS THE
HEALTH CENTER ON CAMPUS OR
WHETHER IF THEY'RE HAVING SOME
ISSUES WITH AGAIN WITH REGARDS
TO WHETHER IT'S HOMELESSNESS
SOME MENTAL HEALTH. ISSUES THAT
THERE ARE CONTACT THAT'S PART
OF THE TRAINING THAT OUR
COACHES GO THROUGH SO THEY KNOW
WHO ARE THE PARTNERS ON. CAMPUS
THAT THEY CAN BRING STUDENTS TO.
WELL FOR THOSE WHO FOLLOW THE-
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS THIS PAST YEAR WE
SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME ON
A MENTAL HEALTH ON THE Q. THREE
TWELVE CAMPUSES IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION CAMPUSES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE ISSUE YOU SEE. AND
HEARD FROM A VARIETY OF
STUDENTS DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD ABOUT CANCELING
THE DELAYS IN IN THE TRAINING
COACHING SERVICES AT A **** A
MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELLING
SERVICES IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
RELATED ISSUES WE DID OUR BEST.
IN OUR. HANNAH AND COMBAT
ALWAYS WITH THE GOVERNOR ON
MONEY TO DRIVE MORE MONEY DOWN
TO CAMPUSES. FOR THAT AND SO
I'M VERY INTERESTED I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE OTHER PANELISTS
COMMENTS ON THIS AS WELL SHARKS
YOUR QUESTION NO. THANK YOU
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR CONTINUED TO BE
AROUND AS WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION. I WANT TO GIVE IT
TO OUR NEXT SPEAKER DOCTOR TO
SEE A KEY TEAR AS LOPEZ. YOU
SERVE AS THAT AND GUESS
RECENTLY CREATED POSITION OF
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT FOR
CAMPUS HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
IN THE DIVISION OF STUDENT
AFFAIRS PRIOR TO YOUR
APPOINTMENT AS SHE ANDERSON WAS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN YOU
SERVED AS DIRECTOR OF
COUNSELING. AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES AT CAL STATE FULLERTON.
ON YOUR AND YOUR DOCTORATE IN
PSYCHOLOGY. AND MASTER'S DEGREE
IN CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OF
PROFESSIONAL PSYCHOLOGY. AND
BEFORE WE- WANTED TO SHARE A-
PERSONAL ANECDOTE ON THIS ISSUE
OF. MENTAL HEALTH. AND WHEN I
WAS A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WE HAD A PRESENTATION
ON. THIS BROADER CATEGORY OF
ISSUES AND I. I ASKED THE
QUESTION. WHAT'S THE AVERAGE
WAIT TIME TO IF SOMEONE SAYS I
AM HAVING A- DIFFICULT TIME
STRESSED OUT. WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE WAIT TIME IN THE C. S.
UCF COUNSELOR. AND THE ANSWER
BACK WAS ABOUT THREE WEEKS.
YESTERDAY DOMINGUEZ HILLS I
ASKED THE- THE DOCTOR IN CHARGE
OF THE COUNSELING PROGRAM TO.
WHAT'S THE ANSWER IT DOING THIS
HILLS I'M STRESSED OUT HAVING A
DIFFICULT TIME. HOW LONG WOULD
IT TAKE ME TO SEE SOMEONE AND
OBVIOUSLY DEPENDING ON THE TIME
OF THE YEAR THAT COULD CHANGE
WE GAVE A VERY WIDE RANGE. HE
SAID WELL WE WOULD SAY BE
BETWEEN FOUR AND EIGHT WEEKS.
FOR AN EIGHT WEEKS FOR SOMEONE
WHO'S UNDER GREAT DEAL OF
STRESS. SO WE LOOK FOR YOUR
INSIGHT AND WISDOM ABOUT HOW
THINGS ARE GOING HERE. AND I DO
FIND IT SAID IT'S A CHALLENGE
FOR US TO NOT JUST DEAL WITH
THE STIGMA. OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND THAT THAT CRAZY STIGMA
WHICH SHOULDN'T BE THERE. BUT
TO GET THE SUPPORT THAT OUR
COUNSELORS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
SERVICE STUDENT BODY LIKE THIS.
LOOK FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING EVERYONE SO
AGAIN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN MY
POSITION AS WELL AS THE AREA OF
STUDENT HEALTH AND WELL BEING
WAS CREATED AND INCLUDED THE
INTEGRATION OF THE FOLLOWING
PROGRAMS STUDENT HEALTH
SERVICES BRONCO WELLNESS WHICH
IS OUR HEALTH EDUCATION AREA
COUNSELING AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTER WHICH ALSO INCLUDES AN
ACHIEVEMENT RETENTION AND
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
SUCCESS GRANT PROGRAM. OUR
INTEGRATED CARE NETWORK AND
SURVIVOR ADVOCACY SERVICES
STUDENT WELLBEING IS A
COMPONENT OF THE INTEGRATED
MODEL OF STUDENT SUCCESS. WE
TAKE AN INTEGRATED APPROACH TO
CARE FOR KIDS FOCUSED ON
HELPING STUDENTS ACHIEVE THEIR
GOALS I KALPI POMONA. WHAT THE
SAME TIME EQUIPPING THEM WITH
THE RIGHT TOOLS NEEDED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL EVEN BEYOND THEIR
TIME HERE. CAL POLY POMONA HAS
A UNIQUE PROGRAM CALLED THE
INTEGRATED CARE NETWORK. THAT
SUPPORTS AND THIS PROGRAM HAS
BEEN IN EXISTENCE FOR A YEAR
NOW. THAT SUPPORTS STUDENTS BY
RAISING THEIR AWARENESS OF
RESOURCES ON AND OFF CAMPUS
THAT CAN HELP THEM SUCCEED IN
SUPPORT THEIR WELL BEING. WITH
THE WARM HAND OFF STUDENTS
EARLY ACADEMIC SUPPORT THE POLY
PANTRY OUR FOOD PANTRY MENTAL
HEALTH COUNSELING WELL BEING
AND LIFE COACHING CRISIS
INTERVENTION SERVICES
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION HEALTH
CARE DISABILITY ACCOMMODATIONS
HEALTH EDUCATION PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICATION SUPPORT. OFF CAMPUS
RESOURCES SUCH AS THE COUNTY
TWO ONE ONE SUPPORT HELPLINE
PROGRAM OR TRI CITY MENTAL
HEALTH AND THE LIST CAN GO ON
AND ON SEVERAL RESOURCES TO BE
FOR STUDENTS TO THE INTEGRATED
CARE NETWORK IS MADE UP OF CARE
COORDINATORS. ON SOME CAMPUSES
YOU HEARD THE PHRASE CASE
MANAGERS HERE WE HAVE CARE
COORDINATORS FROM ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS OF THE WELL BEING
AREA AS WELL AS PARTNERS FROM
ASSOCIATE STUDENTS INCORPORATED
AND UNIVERSITY HOUSING. THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF THE INTEGRATED
CARE NETWORK IS TO PROVIDE A
WEB OF SERVICES THAT ADDRESSES
STUDENTS NEEDS EARLY ON TO
PREVENT ANY OF OUR STUDENTS
FROM FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. THIS IS DONE THROUGH
PREVENTION EDUCATION IN A GREAT
SUPPORT SERVICES EARLY
INTERVENTION AND KEYS K. CRISIS
MANAGEMENT WHEN NECESSARY. WE
TAKE A WRAPAROUND APPROACH TO
CARE IN ORDER TO INSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS HAVE WHAT THEY
NEED TO SUCCEED. THE CARE
COORDINATORS WORK TOGETHER ON A
REGULAR BASIS AND JUST SO YOU
KNOW SOME OF OUR CARE
COORDINATORS METERS ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE SUCCESS
COACHING AS WELL SO THE KERR
CORNERS WORK TOGETHER ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE LINKED. TO THE
APPROPRIATE SERVICE ON OR OFF
CAMPUS. AT TIMES MORE THAN ONE
CARE COORDINATOR MAY BE WORKING
WITH THE SAME STUDENTS SO FOR
EXAMPLE A STUDENT ACCESS C.
WHILE PETER LIFE COACHING OUT
OF COUNSELING AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
SERVICES. AND HOUSING CARE
MANAGEMENT AND LEAKAGE WHILE
LIVING IN HOUSING. MAY ALSO BE
IN NEED OF EMERGENCY FINANCIAL
SUPPORT AND OUR FOOD RESOURCES.
THE AXIS IN OUR BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATORS FOR MORE BOB
BRONCOS KERR BASIC NEEDS
PROGRAM. AND THE POLY PANTRY. I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO SHARE
THAT DURING THE LAST ACADEMIC
YEAR AND OUR FIRST FULL YEAR AS
A NETWORK WE RECEIVED EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
REFERRALS. AND SERVE STUDENTS
ACROSS TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
APPOINTMENTS. FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS SO THE REASONS INCLUDED
MENTAL HEALTH CRISES FOOD AND
HOUSING AND SECURITIES
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALIZATIONS. ADHD AND
AUTISM SPECTRUM SUPPORT AND
JUST TO NAME A FEW. AN AREA TO
HIGHLIGHT. IS THE BRONCOS KERR
BASIC NEEDS PROGRAM AND YOU'LL
SEE THAT ON THIS LIFE THAT'S ON
THE SCREEN. IN FRONT OF YOU.
WHICH IS A COMPREHENSIVE CAMPUS
WIDE INITIATIVE SUPPORTING
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSTABILITY FORTY SECURITY AND
OTHER EMERGENCY CRISIS
SITUATIONS. DURING THE CAL
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM SURVEY
ACID IN BASIC NEEDS CONDUCTED
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND RELEASED
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN. A
RELATIVELY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
OUR STUDENTS FOUR POINT 2%
RESPONDED. HOWEVER OF THESE
RESPONDING C. P. P. STUDENTS
40% REPORTED THAT THEY
EXPERIENCED SOME FORM OF FOOD
AND SECURITY. AND 50% REPORTED
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS.
ALTHOUGH THE RESPONSE RATE WAS
LOW WE ARE SEEING THAT THERE'S
DEFINITELY NEED ON OUR CAMPUS
WE SAW THIS DURING OUR MOBILE
FOOD PANTRY BETH AND NOW ARE
SEEING THAT. IN OUR PHYSICAL
PANTRY UTILIZATION. WE ARE ALSO
ENCOUNTERING MORE STUDENTS THAT
ARE LIVING IN THEIR CARS ARE
BECOMING HOMELESS FOR VARIOUS
REASONS. WE ARE COLLECTING DATA
ON UTILIZATION OF SERVICES AS
WELL AS STUDENTS THAT ATTEND
OUR OUTREACH EVENTS THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR WE ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
CONDUCT OUR OWN STUDENTS SURVEY
TO SEE WHAT THE DATA INCIDENT
BASIC NEEDS LOOKS LIKE TODAY.
THE CALL YOU COULD SEE. WHAT
OUR PROGRAMS ABOUT ON FLIGHT TO
THE GOAL OF OUR BASIC NEEDS
PROGRAM IS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH FOOD RESOURCES. SUCH AS ME
OFFICES VOUCHERS. ACTUALLY
HAVING A PHYSICAL FOOD PANTRY
AND BILL POINTS DONATIONS. I
ALSO HAVE HOUSING SUPPORT SUCH
AS EMERGENCY HOUSING AND HOTEL
VOUCHERS. AN EMERGENCY FUNDS A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR EMERGENCY
GRANT PROGRAMS HOPING TO
INCREASE THAT TWO THOUSAND.
ASIN SUPPORT AS WELL THROUGH
OUR PARTNERSHIPS ACCOUNTING
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES AND CASE
MANAGEMENT LEAKAGE ALL OF WHICH
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN A
STUDENT'S ACADEMIC SUCCESS AND
WEALTHY. THIS IS THE CAMPUS
WIDE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAM FOCUSED
NOT ON NOT ONLY ON PROVIDING
FOOD MONEY AND HOUSING BUT ALSO
ASSISTING OUR STUDENTS IN
DEVELOPING THE NEEDED SKILLS TO
OPTIMIZE THEIR USE OF ALREADY
EXISTING RESOURCES ON AND OFF
CAMPUS SO FOR EXAMPLE STUDENTS
ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT HOW
FRESH. DUE TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CPP CAL
FRESH OUT REACH PROGRAM WHICH
CONSISTS OF FIVE STUDENT
AMBASSADORS SOME OF WHOM HAVE
ALSO AXIS FOR BASIC NEEDS
RESOURCES ARE YOU WILL BE
HEARING FROM THEM LATER ON
TODAY I THINK ONE OF THEM WAS
SURE HER STORY WITH YOU. AND
THEN WE ALSO HAVE ONE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF MEMBER ALSO
SERVES AS OUR BASIC NEEDS
PROGRAM CARE COORDINATOR. AND
WILL BE JOINING US DURING THE
ROUND TABLE DISCUSSION. THE
CALC FRESH PROGRAM HELPS
STUDENTS WITH CAL FRESH PRE
SCREEN APPLICATION PROCESSES
INTERVIEW PREP TROUBLESHOOTING
AND MORE. IN ADDITION TO HAVING
OUR OWN CAL FRESH PROGRAM CAL
POLY POMONA RECENTLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE CALIFORNIA
JOSH OUT REACH DAY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LA FOOD
BASIC HOLLY I'M SORRY THE ONLY
FOOD BANK CALPERS OUTREACH
TEAM. TO BRING LOCAL COUNT
CALORIES ELIGIBILITY WORKERS TO
ASSIST OUR STUDENTS ON THE SPOT
WITH THE APPLICATION PROCESS SO
A PROCESS THAT COULD LAST
THIRTY DAYS WAS DONE IN. THIRTY
MINUTES ON THE SPOT. STUDENTS
WHO ARE. GRANTED CAL FRESH
BENEFITS ARE ABLE TO USE THEIR
EBT CARD ON FOR LOCATION OR
LOCATIONS ON CAMPUS INCLUDING
THE PONY EXPRESS THE MARKET
PLACE THIS TO MARKET AND OUR
FARM STORE. ALSO IN AN EFFORT
TO FURTHER RAISE AWARENESS OF
THE RESOURCES AVAILABLE THIS
NOVEMBER WE WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN OUR SECOND
SECOND HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS
AWARENESS WEEK. IN ADDITION TO
CAL FRESH OUT REACH AS
MENTIONED ALREADY WE HAVE EMAIL
SYSTEMS PROGRAM AND THE POLY
PANTRY AS PART OF OUR FOOD
RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS. AGAIN
WHICH WILL BE VISITING SOON
GIVEN APPROXIMATELY 46% OF C.
P. P. STUDENTS RECEIVE
PARAGRAPH AS 76% OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE AT LEAST SOME
FINANCIAL AID GRATZ. WE REALIZE
WE HAVE MANY STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING NUMEROUS FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES FOR THOSE STUDENTS
WE WORK TO PROVIDE MULTIPLE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES INCLUDING
THE EMERGENCY GRATZ FINANCIAL
AID IN EDUCATION ON FINANCIAL
RESOURCES IN LITERACY. AND
BUILDING BUT. FOR STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOUSING
INSTABILITIES WE OFFER
EMERGENCY HOUSING THROUGH
UNIVERSITY HOUSING SERVICES AND
HOTEL VOUCHERS FOR STUDENTS
WITH DEPENDENT CHILDREN. IN
ADDITION WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
THE PROCESS OF APPLYING FOR THE
EIGHTY SEVENTY FOUR AND RAPID
RE HOUSING FUNDS TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND HAVE
AND HOPE TO BE ABLE TO FURTHER
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS THIS WAY
WELL WE HAVE WORKED TO
UNDERSTAND OUR STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS AND ADDRESS THEM. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR EFFORTS MUST
INCLUDE PROVIDING LEÓN EDGE TO
COMMUNITY RESOURCES I WE HAVE
CONNECT DISSIDENTS TO THOSE
RESOURCES SPECIFICALLY THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESSNESS SERVICES
STORY SO I SEATS FOR LIFE AND
THE ALLEY FEEDBACK. JUDY
HAARETZ OUR BASIC NEEDS CARE
SERVICES COORDINATOR CURRENTLY
ATTENDS REGULAR MEETINGS AND
WORKS AT THE ALLEY HOMELESSNESS
SECURITY AUTHORITY TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS. THROUGH THESE
EFFORTS ARE STUDENTS ARE
CONNECTED TO THE YOUTH
CORONATED ENTRY SYSTEM AS AN
ASIDE JUDY JUST SHARED WITH ME
THAT THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESSNESS SERVICE ALREADY IS
LOOKING TATTERED POSITION THAT
WILL FOCUS ON WORKING WITH
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITIES AROUND
THE AREA OF HOUSING AND
SECURITY. SHE REMAINS IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH THEM. TO ENSURE
THEIR CAMPUS CAN BE PART OF
THESE VERY IMPORTANT EFFORTS.
IN THE AREA OF MENTAL HEALTH WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
OUR CAMPUS LEADERSHIP TO
ADDRESS OUR STUDENT NEEDS. OUR
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIOS ARE
IMPROVING. WE'RE GOING FROM ONE
TO TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR. BASED
ON ENROLLMENT. LAST FALL TWO
ONE AND TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTY
FIVE BASED ON CURRENT
ENROLLMENT. AND AS YOU KNOW
ENROLLMENT HAS BROWN SO.
ACTUALLY OUR NUMBERS ARE MOVING
IN THE IN THE VERY RIGHT
DIRECTION. AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THAT THIS IMPROVEMENT HAS
HAPPENED TO GAINING THE
APPROVAL FROM OUR PRESIDENT. TO
HIRE THREE NEW CANCERS AND
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR ALSO
PROVIDES DRUG COUNSELING
SERVICES. ARE COUNSELING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES NOW
OFFERS. MORE WELL BEING
WORKSHOPS FOCUSING ON AREAS
THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE TELLING
US THEY NEED TO HEAR LEARN MORE
ABOUT. AND GET MORE HELP ON SO
SUCH AS ANXIETY STRESS
MANAGEMENT SELF CARE BALANCE
COPING WITH EMOTIONS AND SELF
ESTEEM. WE ALSO OFFER DROPPING
GROUPS HELD IN VARIOUS
LOCATIONS ACROSS CAMPUS
INCLUDING ATHLETICS OUR
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER AS
WELL AS OUR CULTURE CULTURAL
CENTERS. AND WELL BEING AND
LIFE COACHING WHICH IS THE
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS THAT CAN
HELP TO FACILITIES STUDENTS
PERSONAL. ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH BY FOCUSING
ON LIFE SKILLS AND WILL BE
COACHING IS NOT COUNSELING OR
THERAPY. AND STUDENTS HAVE
SHOWN THAT THEY THEY ARE
ACTUALLY IMPROVING AND FEELING
THAT WHAT THEY NEEDED WAS THE
COACHING PIECE SO THAT ALLOWS
FOR STUDENTS WHO NEED THE
COUNSELING AND THERAPY. TO
ACCESS THOSE SERVICES. OUR
THREE NEW COUNTS ARE POSITIONS
THAT WE WILL BE PROVIDING
SERVICES FOR HOUSING I
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE LOCATIONS. OUTSIDE
OF A TRADITIONAL KELSEY CENTER
MODEL TAKING THE SERVICE WHERE
THE STUDENT AS- TO THESE
POSITIONS WILL ALSO HAVE
DIFFERENT HOURS ALLOWING FOR
MORE EVENING SERVICES. LASTLY
WE ARE INCREASING OUR EFFORTS
AROUND SUICIDE AWARENESS AND
PREVENTION LAST YEAR WE HAD OUR
FIRST SON SCIENCE PACKING.
EVENTS AND I'M NOT SURE IF
YOU'VE EVER SEEN IT WHERE THEY
LAY OUT. A HUGE NUMBER OF
BACKPACKS EACH REPRESENTING A
PERSON HAS TAKEN THEIR LIFE BE
A SUICIDE AND EACH BACKPACK HAS
THE STORY IT'S REALLY IMPACTFUL
WITH C. IT'S DONE. IN A BIG
AREA OF CAMPUS AND PEOPLE STOP
BY LISTEN. AND READ THE STORIES
AND THEN LEARN ABOUT TALKING
ABOUT SUICIDE AND ALSO. RAISING
AWARENESS ABOUT MENTAL ILLNESS
AND MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT. WE
ARE ALSO. THIS YEAR SO THAT WAS
LAST YEAR THIS YEAR WE ARE
IMPLEMENTING SOURCES OF
STRENGTH. WHICH IS A PROGRAM
THAT FOCUSES ON STIGMA
REDUCTION ALSO SUICIDE
PREVENTION AND AWARENESS AND IT
INVOLVES PURE PURE PARTNERS AS
WELL AS FACULTY SERVING AS
MENTORS. I HOPE THAT YOU FIND.
THE L. AND THE N. THESE
PROGRAMS ARE ALL COLLABORATION
WITH ALL THE AREAS THAT I
MENTIONED FROM THE AREA OF
STUDENT HEALTH AND WELLBEING. I
HOPE THAT YOU FIND THIS
INFORMATION HELPFUL AND A YOU
GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT ALL OF OUR WELL
BEING EFFORTS AT CAL POLY
POMONA DURING YOUR VISIT THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
FOR YOUR GENUINE CAN CONCERN
FOR STUDENTS FOR THE WELL BEING
OF OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
DR. DEAREST LOPEZ APPRECIATE
YOUR OVERVIEW OF ALL THE
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE ON THE CAMPUS. AT A
COUPLE OF FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
FIRST LET ME JUST SAY. THANK
YOU AND PRAISE FOR THE
ADDITIONAL THREE COUNSELORS. AT
THE AT THAT IN THE CENTER. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THE RATIO OF US
STUDENTS TO COUNSELORS THAT. IN
TERMS OF BEST PRACTICES AS A
COUNSELOR FOR EVERY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS. SOLANA
IMPROVEMENT FROM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TO ONE IS TO TWENTY. AT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND ONE IS A IS
GOOD THERE'S STILL ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT THERE YES AND
HERE'S THE PROVERBIAL QUESTION
I'M A STUDENT HERE AT POMONA.
AND I'M VERY VERY STRESSED OUT.
AND THAT I NEED SOMEONE TO TALK
TO. AN OUTHOUSE AND CAN I GET
AN APPOINTMENT IF IT'S AN
URGENT MATTER HANNAH CRISIS YOU
CAN SEE SOMEONE. J. IF IT ISN'T
IN OUR J. CRISIS MATTER YOU CAN
SEE SOMEONE WITHIN ONE TO TWO
WEEKS SOMEONE TWO WEEKS IS THE-
IS THE ANSWER. AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED TO
WORK ON AND TRY TO IMPROVE UPON
BECAUSE- IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
REALLY STRESSED OUT AND YOU'RE
REACHING OUT. IT'S NOT USUALLY
AND IF YOU'RE NOT SAYING THE
WORD SUICIDE OR TAKING YOUR OWN
LIFE FOR HARMING YOURSELF.
YOU'RE GONNA BE IN THAT THAT.
THAT GROUP THAT'S GONNA HAVE TO
SIT AROUND AND WAIT AWHILE.
UNDER GREAT DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT NO ONE WOULD
WANT ANYONE TO THE KIND OF FACE.
DO YOU WHAT WHAT DO YOU DO WHAT
YOU DO WHAT YOU DO ON THE
CAMPUS TO DE STIGMATIZE.
COUNSELING MENTAL HEALTH.
ASSISTANCE WHAT WHAT WHAT
EFFORTS TO GO ON TO. HELP
IMPROVE THAT RELATIONSHIP. I
THINK DEFINITELY WHEN WE HAVE
BIG CAMPUS WIDE EVENTS SUCH AS
THE SUN SIGNS BACKING THAT
SENSE THAT. GIVES THE MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH AND THAT WE WANT
SINCE YOU SEE THAT OTHERS ARE
EXPERIENCING CONCERNS THAT ARE
RELATED TO MENTAL HEALTH WE
HAVE WE OFFER WORKSHOPS IN MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS ON CAMPUS SO
THAT STUDENTS CAN. FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE ATTENDING AMENITY.
FOR TO MY CLASSES IN THE ROOM
WHO ELSE WANTS TO ASK ABOUT.
RATHER THAN WAIT WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS WEEK I KNOW AND HAVE
A LOT OF EVENTS GOING ON.
AROUND IT NO AND I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT AND I THINK AS A
STUDENT LEADER SAID TO ME. THIS
MORNING THAT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT A WEEK IT'S A GOOD THING
TO HAVE A WEEK WE FOCUS ON IT.
BUT IT'S REALLY FIFTY TWO WEEKS
A BOX OF RECENTLY WE HAVE AN
INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT AND WE'RE
SHARING A LOT OF INFORMATION
ACTUALLY ACROSS ALL THE SOCIAL
MEDIA. FOR THAT WELLBEING AREA
WE SHARE FOR ALL AREAS SO
HEALTH AND COUNSELING AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CENTER WE
CROSS SHARE AND WE HAVE
STUDENTS. COMMENTING ON THAT.
THAT'S THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR.
DROPPING I START NANCY RATHER
THAN. WE ALSO HAVE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE ALSO HAVE DROP IN
GROUPS EVERY MONTH AND CHATS
AND DIFFERENT CENTERS ACROSS
CULTURAL CENTERS DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS OF PRESENTATIONS
THAT WE DO REQUEST OF DIFFERENT
INSTRUCTORS ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THIS IS IT IN DISTRESS HOW TO
MANAGE ANXIETY TEST TAKING AND
JUST DIFFERENT THINGS SO WE TRY
TO MAKE A PRESENCE IN DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS ON CAMPUS BY REQUEST
AND ALSO. ALSO IN DIFFERENT
EVENTS LIKE DIFFERENT FARES WE
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE. YEAH THOSE
MARTYRS COMING AND COMING UP IN
NOVEMBER AND ARE LATER IN
OCTOBER AND FOR THAT DAY WERE
DOING A REMEMBRANCE AND WE'RE
USING A MENTAL HEALTH FAME SO
WE TRY TO PARTICIPATE IN
DIFFERENT EVENTS SO THAT THE
MENTAL HEALTH THEME IS PRESENT
IN. MIKE TALKED ABOUT THAT'S
VERY GOOD. DO YOU DO ANY DATA
COLLECTION OF STUDENTS IN TERMS
OF THEIR ISSUES OF STRESS AND
MENTAL HEALTH. YES AND WE ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NATIONAL
COLLEGE HEALTH ASSESSMENT.
THAT'S WHERE WE GET OUR GOT THE
NUMBERS AROUND ANXIETY
DEPRESSION AND STRESS AND ALSO
SLEEP. YES NO THAT'S GOOD TO
HEAR AT THE CAMPUS WE WERE AT
YESTERDAY THE DATA THAT THEY
GOT FROM THEIR STUDENT BODY WAS
THAT. OF 14% ATKINS AT
CONSIDERED TAKING THEIR OWN
LIFE. THE PAST YEAR 14% SO
THERE'S THAT. JUST SAID WHICH
ARE SICK IS IT'S CRITICAL TO
WHAT WE ARE ALL FOCUSING ON
HERE ACCOUNT MIKE THE MONA IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN
STUDENTS FIRST ARRIVE SO WE
HAVE TOTALLY CHANGED OUR
ORIENTATION PROGRAM OF FOCUSING
ON SPEECH STUDENTS AS THEY COME
INTO THE UNIVERSITY SO THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF AREAS THAT MAY AFFECT
YOUR ABILITY TO MATRICULATING.
IN THERE MAY BE PHYSICAL THERE
MAY BE MENTAL HEALTH THERE MAY
BE JUST NOT KNOWING HOW TO
NAVIGATE THIS LARGE UNIVERSITY
AND SO THE FOCUS HAS BEEN TO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE. TO MAKE THE STUDENTS
AWARE. ON AN AS NEEDED BASIS
BECAUSE MANY TIMES THE STUDENTS
AREN'T IT'S NOT UNTIL THEY GO
TO THEIR FIRST SEMESTER THAT WE
FIND THAT. THE STRESS THE
ANXIETY AND SO FORTH AND SO WE
WANT TO WANT TO NOT ONLY WITH
ACCESS TO BILLY CHAT WITH
COMING INTO THE UNIVERSITY THE
ORIENTATION SESSIONS ARE MAKING
THEM AWARE AND NORMALIZING.
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A STUDENT
AN INDIVIDUAL WHERE WE ALL HAVE
STRESSORS THAT ALL HAVE
PROBLEMS THAT WE WANT TO
SUPPORT YOU IN IN ADDRESSING SO
YOUR POINT ABOUT IT NOT JUST. A
ONE WEEK IT IS A ROW HOW DO WE
INSTITUTIONALIZE IN FACT WHAT
IS ARE ON OUR ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS AND DEAL WITH THOSE
BARRIERS THAT PREVENT YOU FROM
HAVING THE SUCCESS THAT WE
EXPECT UP YOU. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT AND BEFORE I GO TO
SENATOR ROTH ONE OF THE
ADVANTAGES OF GOING TO A LOT OF
COLLEGE CAMPUSES YOU GET TO
HEAR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PRACTICES IN SOME CASES YOU
KNOW BEST PRACTICES AND- ONE OF
THE TAKE AWAYS FROM ONE OF OUR
CAMPUS VISITS WAS THE FACULTY
REPRESENTATIVE SAYING THAT. AS
A PART OF EVERY SYLLABUS IN A
CLASS AT THE BOTTOM OF THE
PAGE. IS A AN EXPLANATION
INFORMATION ABOUT BASIC NEED
ISSUES. I THOUGHT WOW THAT'S
THAT'S REALLY CONNECTING IT TO.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE THINK IS THE
HEART OF THE UNIVERSITY WRITE
THE ACADEMICS BUT YET WE HAVE
TO NOW IT'S THE WHOLE PERSON
HAS TO BE THERE IF IT'S OVER TO
BE SUCCESSFUL SO I SURE THAT. A
BEST PRACTICES SENATE ROTH.
THANK YOU MR TRUMP I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT HOW THE MENTAL
HEALTH. COUNSELING PEACE WORKS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CANCERS OF
THE HEALTH PRACTITIONER.
PSYCHOLOGISTS SOCIAL WORKERS OR
SOMETHING ELSE I'LL BE ABOUT WE
HAVE. LIFE PSYCHOLOGIST WE HAVE
LICENSED MARRIAGE FAMILY.
COUNSELLING TREATMENTS SO I'VE
STUDENTS ARE REFERRED OUT IF
THEY HAVE. THEY NEED MORE
LONGER TERM TREATMENT SO WE
HAVE ALSO WHAT WE HAVE OUR
WELLBEING COACH ALSO SERVES AS
OUR CASE MANAGER. WAS THIS THE
STUDENT IN MAKING THAT
CONNECTION WITH AND OUTSIDE
RESOURCES AND ENSURES THAT THE
WARM HAND OFF OCCURS SO NOT
JUST GIVING THEM THE NUMBER BUT
ENSURING THAT THEY ACTUALLY GET
CONNECTED. THAT'S FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE MORE LONGER TERM WE DO
OFFER. SOME LONG TERM CASES BUT
NOT EVERY CANCER CAN CAN NOT AT
WE CAN'T HAVE ALL STUDENTS BE
LONG TERM CARE. SO WHEN THE
WHEN THE WARM HAND OFF OCCURS
IN THE STUDENTS IS ASSISTED
WITH THE- OUTSIDE REFERRAL WHO
PAYS FOR THE OUTSIDE SERVICES
RYAN WELL WHEN THE HAVE
INSURANCE. THEIR PRIVATE
INSURANCE BUT THAT IS AN AREA.
OF NEED DEFINITELY A BASIC
NEEDS THAT SOME STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE THE FUNDING FOR THAT SO WE
DO TAKE ON SOME OF THIS IS THAT
WE TAKE ON LONG TERM. OUR
STUDENTS WHO CANNOT ACTUALLY
AFFORD IT. RIGHT AND THE REASON
I ASKED THE QUESTION YOU KNOW
WE- AS I SAID IT WAS ALWAYS
HANNAH HAD COME BUT WITH THE
BUDGET WE WERE ABLE TO PUT
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR. FOR ADDITIONAL MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES SOME OF THAT
HIGHER EDUCATION NOT NEARLY.
ENOUGH FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
FRANKLY NOT NEARLY NEARLY
ENOUGH FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE. I
ASKED THE QUESTION BECAUSE I
REALIZE ALTHOUGH WE NEED TO DO
MORE FOR THE UC SYSTEM AS WELL
BUT THERE IS A- WHAT ABOUT A
MAJOR DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE UC
SYSTEM IN THE C. ISSUE
INSTITUTION AND THAT'S YOU SEE
HEALTH AND THAT'S THE INSURANCE
OF PROGRAMS THAT. THE UC
PROVIDES SO. FOR ITS. STUDENTS
PROBABLY MANDATES AS I RECALL.
AND FOR C. ISSUE IS
HISTORICALLY NOT DONE THAT DO
WE HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR- STUDENT
POPULATION IS SOMEHOW COVERED
BY. INSURANCE IT INCLUDES
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE COVERAGE
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER. I DON'T
HAVE THAT NUMBER WITH WE CAN
GET IT IT'LL BE SOMETHING THAT
I'LL BE TALKING TO THE
INSTITUTION ABOUT WHEN WE START
THE BUDGET CONVERSATION THIS
YEAR. BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CRACK THAT NOT. WE'RE EITHER
GONNA HAVE TO PROVIDE MORE
MONEY. TO THE INSTITUTION INTO
THE INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES TO BE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH COUNSELING
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS OR WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDENTS
HAVE THE INSURANCE COVERAGE
THAT THEY NEED TO PROVIDE AT
LEAST SOME. PORTION OF MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES THE WE CAN'T
PROVIDE ON THE CAMPUS SO. THANK
YOU MR LINCOLN CENTER ON A
RECESSION VERY GOOD CENTER
CHANG. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
SPECIFIC DATA BEHIND THE MENTAL
HEALTH WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
DRIVEN BY. ACTIVITIES AT THE
SCHOOL OR SITUATION AT FIRST
BUT FOR A FIFTH SEVEN STRESSORS
THE DISTRESS LARA WE DO HAVE
INFORMATION AROUND THAT SOME OF
THE STUDENTS ALREADY COME INTO
CAMPUS WITH PRE EXISTING MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS SUBSTANCE ARE
EXPERIENCING TRAUMA MAYBE TRY
MEXICAN C. WHILE IN SCHOOL
BASED ON A LOST A FAMILY MEMBER
OR- YOU KNOW IT DRAMATIC
SITUATIONS SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT
MIGHT OCCUR. SO THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE REASONS WHY THEY'RE
SHARING BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING
MORE AS AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS COMING AND
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS
ALREADY AND EVEN IN THE
SEVERITY OF. WHAT THEY'RE
PRESENTING WITH IN TERMS OF
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
WE DO HAVE THAT I CAN SHARE
THOSE WITH. THAT'S A GREAT AND
IN TERMS OF HOUSING AND THIS IS
JUST MY BEING OFF THE WHOLE
QUESTION BUT I STARTED NOTICING
THIS A LOT ON. ON YOUTUBE WHERE
STUDENTS ARE NOW LIVING OFF THE
GRID. BECAUSE THEY CHOOSE TO
THAT THE BAND LIKE THE CAUGHT
THE BAND LIFE AND THEY- CHOOSE
TO DO THOSE THOSE US STUDENTS
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS HOMELESS.
I'M GOING TO DEFER THAT TO OUR
BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR JUDY
ARE YOU SEEING THAT. AT HELLO
MY NAME IS JUDY AND THE BASIC
NEEDS COORDINATOR I HAVE SEEN
THAT AS STUDENTS WHO DO
IDENTIFY WITH THE VAN LIFE AS
YOU MENTIONED. AND THEY DO
CONSIDER THEMSELVES SELVES
HOMELESS ON THE STUDENTS THAT I
DO WORK WITH WE TALK ABOUT
RESOURCES AND THE RESOURCES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE BOTH SHORT
TERM AND LONG TERM SHORT TERM
MEANING ARE TEMPORARY
UNIVERSITY HOUSING. AND LONG
TERM IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
LOOKING AT HOW CAN WE GET THE
STUDENT YOU KNOW ADJUSTED THEIR
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE HOW DO WE
GET THEM CONNECTED WITH SOME
REGULAR INCOME SO LOOKING IN. I
CONNECTING THEM WITH SERVICES
SUCH AS CAL FIRST CAL WORKS BUT
ALSO SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY
I WILL SAY THAT WORKING WITH
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS OR IT'S
JUST STUDENTS THAT ARE OUTSIDE
OF THE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY SIX
RANGE. IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
SEE TO GET SERVICES IN THE
COMMUNITY FOR FOLKS OUTSIDE OF
THAT COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY'RE HOMELESS SO THINKING
ABOUT A STUDENT WHO MIGHT BE.
THIRTY FIVE YEARS OLD AND
LIVING ON THEIR OWN HOMELAND
SIME AND WITHOUT ANY CHILDREN
THE SERVICES IN THE COMMUNITY
ARE A LOT LESS COMPARED TO A
STUDENT WHO IS EIGHTEEN AND
HOMELESS ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
STUDENTS WHO HAVE FAMILIES AS
WELL. SO I AM. DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION YEAH. OKAY
SENATORS NANCY SOMETHING ON ONE
OF THE STUDENT YOU IDENTIFY
YOURSELF MY NAME'S LOUIS BUT TO
COLONEL I'M A STUDENT HERE AT
CAL POLY POMONA. I'VE BEEN
RECENTLY WENT THROUGH SOME
FINANCIAL NEEDS AND HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS AND- I JUST WANNA
THING JUDY WHAT IS SHE'S
AMAZING. FOR THE WORK THAT SHE
DOES I KNOW MY SCENE THE
NUMBERS. NOW THEY LOOKING GOOD
AND THE- AND THE DATABASES BUT
THEY'RE REALLY GRATEFUL STAFF
COORDINATORS. AND I'M REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
STORY THANK YOU AND I'M SURE
IT'S REPEATED MANY TIMES OVER
BY MANY OTHERS. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT I KNOW WE'RE GONNA
TOUR THE FOOD FOOD PANTRY AFTER
THE GERMAN OF THIS HEARING. AND
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THAT SOMEONE
THANK YOU THE DOCTOR. THE TEARS
LOPEZ FEARED. DETESTS MONEY ALL
YOUR GOOD WORK IN LEADERSHIP
HERE ON THE CAMPUS. SO NEXT UP
TRACY. IS IT BUSY SAKE. A
SECOND. THANK YOU TRACY FOR
BEING HERE YOU'RE THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DISABILITY RESOURCE
CENTER. HERE ON THE CAMPUS.
PRIOR TO YOUR ROLE HERE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT YOU WORKED AS AN
ASSOCIATE ATHLETIC DIRECTOR.
HERE AS WELL AS AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND AT YALE.
YOU ARE IN A LAW DEGREE FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF OREGON. AND A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN HISTORY
FROM SAN FRANCISCO STATE. AND
YOU'RE GONNA STAY SHARE YOUR
STORY AND YOUR INSIGHT ON THE
ROLE OF DISABILITY READ THE
RESOURCE CENTER. HELPING
STUDENTS HERE ON THE CAMPUS. SO
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU. THE D. R. C. WITHIN THE
CLUSTER OF STUDENT HEALTH AND
WELL BEING IS THE DEPARTMENT ON
CAMPUS THAT DETERMINES
APPROPRIATE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
THEIR EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
THE D. R. C. WORKS CLOSELY WITH
FACULTY TO PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
AND GUIDANCE. NEEDED TO CREATE
AN INCLUSIVE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT FOR A COUPLE OF
MONNING STUDENTS. BY PARTNERING
WITH FACULTY WE COLLECTIVELY
ENSURE STUDENTS EXPERIENCE
ACCESS IN THEIR COURSE. WORK
THROUGH ACCOMMODATIONS OR OTHER
OUTCOMES. IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ACT HELP HOLLY
POMONA HAS MORE THAN TRIPLED.
WITH JUST OVER FOUR HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
TO PROTECTED TWELVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS BY THE END OF THIS
ACADEMIC YEAR. THIS REPRESENTS
ABOUT 3% OF THE UNDERGRADUATE
POPULATION. HOWEVER NATIONAL
DATA TELLS US THAT ROUGHLY 11%
OF ALL ENROLLED UNDERGRADUATES
HAVE A DISABILITY. ALTHOUGH OUR
NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED
IMMENSELY THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
KAPALI POMONA STUDENTS WHO
COULD POTENTIALLY QUALIFY FOR
SERVICES. WELL OUR DATA SHOWS
GROWTH IN ALL DISABILITY TYPES
THE AREA WITH THE LARGEST
INCREASES MENTAL HEALTH. WITHIN
THE LAST FIVE YEARS STUDENTS
SEEKING ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES HAS
INCREASED BY OVER ONE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY PERCENT. THE DEER C.
HAVE STRENGTHEN OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH COUNSELING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO ARE
BEING SEEN BY CAPS FOR
COUNSELLING. ARE ALSO THEN
BEING REFERRED TO THE D. R. C.
FOR THE ACADEMIC ACCOMMODATIONS
AND SUPPLEMENTAL SUPPORTS THEY
NEED TO PERSIST. THESE TYPES OF
COLLABORATIONS ARE CRITICAL TO
CONNECTING STUDENTS TO
ACCOMMODATIONS WHEN THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE HAVE NOT BEEN AWARE
THAT THEY WERE ELIGIBLE FOR D.
R. C. SERVICES. THE DEER C.
ALSO SUPPORT STUDENTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH DISABILITIES
THROUGH INVOLVEMENT IN OUR
CAMPUSES INTEGRATIVE CARE
NETWORK. DEAR C. CURRENTLY HAS
TO STOP SERVING AS CARE
COORDINATORS WITHIN THE
NETWORK. THESE INDIVIDUALS NOT
ONLY PRESCRIBE ACCOMMODATIONS
BUT THEY SEEK TO IMPROVE ACCESS
AND CONNECTIONS TO RESOURCES
THROUGH COORDINATED EFFORTS.
SENDING US APART FROM OTHER
CAMPUSES IS OUR CARE
COORDINATORS STUDENT SUCCESS
COACHING. OUR ARTISAN
SPECIALIST PROVIDES ENGAGEMENT
COACHING A PROGRAM THAT FOCUSES
ON THE DEVELOPMENT OF STUDENT'S
SELF DETERMINATION. THIS
INCLUDES SELF AWARENESS SELF
ADVOCACY AND BEHAVIORAL SELF
REGULATION. OUR ADHD SPECIALIST
PROVIDES EXECUTIVE SKILLS
COACHING. A STRING SPACE
PROGRAMS THAT ASSIST STUDENTS
IN OVERCOMING EXECUTIVE
FUNCTIONING CHALLENGES
INCLUDING TIME MANAGEMENT.
PLANNING AND ORGANIZATION. THIS
EIGHT WEEK PROGRAM WAS
INTRODUCED THIS PAST WINTER AND
HAD AN IMMEDIATE WAIT LIST
WHICH ONLY DEMONSTRATES
STUDENTS NEEDS FOR THESE TYPES
OF SERVICES. LASTLY THE DRC
INITIATED A PEER MENTORING
PROGRAM WHERE D. R. C. STUDENTS
APPEARS MET REGULARLY TO
DISCUSS ACADEMIC CHALLENGES.
AND A LITTLE MORE THAN SIX
MONTHS IN EXISTENCE DEAR C.
STUDENTS PARTICIPATED IN OVER
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
COACHING. AND TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PEER MENTORING SESSIONS.
THESE TYPES OF SUPPORT SERVICES
IN ADDITION TO MANDATED
ACCOMMODATIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
ENSURING STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES SUCCEED. THE DEER
C. CONTINUES TO LOOK AT
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO INCREASE
RETENTION AND GRADUATION RATES
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
WELL THE DEER SHE'S PRIMARY
ROLE IS TO PRY IT IS TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO ACCOMMODATIONS WE
RECOGNIZED AXIS ALONE HAS NOT
MET THE STUDENTS UNIQUE NEEDS
AND ACHIEVING ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
IN ADDITION TO THE CARE
COORDINATORS WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF HIRING AN ACADEMIC
OUTREACH ADVISER WHO WILL
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL RISING AND
DEVELOP A NEW PEER TUTORING
PROGRAM. THE DEER SHE'S PULLED
TO MY GOAL IS TO CREATE A
CENTER THAT WILL PROVIDE EACH
STUDENT WITH AN INDIVIDUALIZED
PLAN OF SERVICES. INCLUDING
SUPPLEMENTAL ADVISING
DISABILITY MANAGEMENT CAREER
AND GRADUATE SCHOOL GUIDANCE
PEER TUTORING AND MENTORING AND
REALLY A HOME BASED UPON TO
FOSTER A SENSE OF CONNECTION
THAT WILL COURAGE THEM TO SEEK
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
PERSIST AND GRADUATE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE GOOD WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE AND- YOUR
TESTIMONY IS STILL A JARRING
GIVEN THE DEMANDS THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED THAT. ARE HERE ON
THE CAMPUS THAT. SPEAKS TO THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT YOU PLAY.
THANK YOU YEAH QUESTION. SO I
JUST LOSE MY MIKE. SEEMS LIKE
IT IS. YOU GUYS HEAR THAT. THAT
ONE. LIMA. GOOD FOR VERSION
THERE WE GO OKAY ALL RIGHT. IF
IT FICTION THEY HAVE KILLED THE
BATTERY OKAY. SO NEXT UP IS A
MAYBE THE ONE MOST IMPORTANT
FOLKS TO SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS
WITH US TODAY I DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO VISIT PRIOR TO THE
HEARING WITH RACHEL RACHEL
HUNTER YOU'RE THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE ASSOCIATE
STUDENTS REGULATIONS FOR THAT.
LEADERSHIP POSITION YOU'RE
THIRTY YOUR POLITICAL SCIENCE
FORTY FOUR HERE I THINK I
GRADUATE. GET A GRADUATED. IN
SPRING YEAH YEAH THAT'S IN THE-
BUT WE THANK YOU FOR. THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND FOR SHARING THAT THE
STUDENTS YOU WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE AND THE CAMPUS AND SUPPORT
AREAS THANK YOU RACHEL THANK
YOU A GOOD MORNING. THROUGHOUT
MY FOUR YEARS BEEN ACTIVELY
INVOLVED WITH MY MAJOR CLUBS
AND AS I. STERN GOVERNMENT I'VE
EXPERIENCED THE EVOLUTION OF
THE RESPONSE TO OUR STUDENTS
FOOD INSECURITY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STUDENT LEADERS PAST
THE S. I. SENATE BILL THE POLY
PANTRY COMMITTING STUDENT
DOLLARS TO IDENTIFYING THE NEED
FUNNY IN A FULL TIME POSITION
AND ESTABLISHING A AND
ACCESSIBLE LOCATION FOR
PERMANENT FOOD PANTRY. BEFORE
THE POLY PANTRY WAS ESTABLISHED
CAL POLY POMONA COLLABORATED
WITH EXTERNAL PARTNERS LIKE SO
IN FUTURE LIFE TOP MOBILE FOOD
PANTRIES TO ASSIST STUDENTS IN
IMMEDIATE NEED. WELL AS I WAS
WORKING ON THE POLY PANTRY THE
UNIVERSITY WAS WORKING ON THE
ENTRY. INTEGRATED CARE NETWORK
ALLOWING THE S. I. KERR QUARTER
TO BE INCORPORATED INTO THIS
NETWORK. THIS NETWORK HAS
CONNECTED STUDENTS TO MUCH
NEEDED RESOURCES AND GIVING
CONSTANT OPPORTUNITIES PER
STUDENT LEADERS TO BE AT THE
TABLE ADVOCATING FOR STUDENTS
NEEDS. OUR CAMPUS HAS MADE THE
CONTINUAL COMMITMENT TO
STALKING THE POLY PANTRY FOR
COORDINATING STRATEGIC CHANGES
THAT HELP COMBAT THE INCREASING
NEED. OUR CLUBS AND
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE RISEN TO THE
CHALLENGE BY TAILORING THEIR
EVENTS ROUND DONATING FOOD. THE
AGRICULTURAL CLUBS HAVE CHOSEN
TO MAKE THE POLY PANTRY PART OF
THEIR ACT BEAUTIFICATION
PROJECT ENCOURAGING THEIR
MEMBERS TO TONY BACK TO THE
CAMPUS COMMUNITY. THE
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES
DONATED OVER FOUR THOUSAND
CANCER THE POLY PEAR TREE AS A
COMPETITION AMONG THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS. AND THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE CLUBS
ENCOURAGE THEIR MEMBERS TO
DONATE THEIR TIME TO THE HOLLY
PANTRY. AMONG THE UNIVERSITY
THERE ALSO SHIPS SHIPS TO HELP
AS WELL. UP ALL CONFERENCE ONE
OF THE UNIVERSITY'S BIGGEST
EVENTS THEIR DECORATIONS ARE
PURELY ITEMS THAT CAN BE
DONATED DONATED BACK TO THE
HOLLY PANTRY. ADDITIONALLY SOME
SERVICE LEARNING COURSES HAVE
YOU NEVER EVEN ALLOWED STUDENTS
TO VOLUNTEER AT THE PANTRY. FOR
CREDIT IN THEIR COURSES. AS THE
POLY PANTRY GO GROWS. STUDENT
LEADERS ARE ATTEMPTING TO
EXPAND THE SERVICES OFFERED
OFFERED BY A SITE IN THE
UNIVERSITY. THERE ARE
CONNECTIONS WITH SOWING SEEDS
FOR LIFE WE HAVE PARLAYED WE
HAVE PILOTED A PROGRAM TO OFFER
FREE MITCHELL PRODUCTS AN ACE I
OWN FACILITIES. IN S. I. WE
AMPLIFY THE STUDENT VOICE BY
CULTIVATING VITAL STUDENT
PROGRAMS SERVICES AND SPACES TO
CREATE THE CONDITIONS FOR
COMMUNITY AND SELF. FULFILLMENT
IN ORDER TO AMPLIFY
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
VOICES YES I STUDENT GOVERNMENT
HAS CREATED THREE NEW POSITIONS
THE SI OFFICER BASIC MEANS
OFFICER DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
AND OFFICER TRANSFER
ENGAGEMENT. THE STUDENTS HAVE
WORKED TIRELESSLY TO CREATE AND
COLLABORATE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
ON INITIATIVES LIKE HUNGER AND
HOMELESS WEEK NATIONAL TRANSFER
WEAK AND CAMPUS CLIMATE EVENTS.
IN ALL OF THESE PROJECTS AND
INITIATIVES YES I AM UNIVERSITY
WORK HAND IN HAND TO HELP
STUDENTS KNOW THAT THEY BELONG
HERE CAL POLY POMONA. TEST OR
RACHEL THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
TO YOUR STUDENT. COMMUNITY FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
UNIVERSITY SAY HERE THAT IN A
LOT OF YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT. THESE THINGS JUST DIDN'T
HAPPEN BECAUSE ONE IT'S C. SAID
WE CARE BUT- EVERYBODY WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE PRESIDENT.
HOLLY AND YOUR STAFF ALL HE
WOULD SAY ASIDE AND ADVANCE
THESE INITIATIVES ARE. IT'S
GOOD TO GOOD TO HEAR ABOUT.
ABOUT AND THAT. WE HAVE
RECENTLY THIS THIS PAST YEAR
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE ARE
NUMBER OF CIVIC AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION GROUPS. THEY HAVE
NOW DONATED WE HAVE ONE GROUP
THIS NON DONATED FROM THEIR
FUND RAISER TO THE A. S. I.
POLY PANTRY AND SOME OF THE
MEMBERS. OF THIS COMMUNITY
GROUP NOW VOLUNTEER TO WORK IN
THE POLY PANTRY A PARTICULAR
POINT SO THE COMMUNITY IS ALSO
VERY MUCH BECOMING A PART. OF
THIS BORDER BORDER AFTER IT.
THAT'S REALLY GOOD TO HEAR AND-
MAYBE I ASKED THE OBVIOUS
QUESTION YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR
FOUR YEARS AND I KNOW YOUR
ENGAGEMENT. IN STUDENT
LEADERSHIP IS NOT JUST STARTED
YOUR ONE BUT IN EACH OF THESE
AREAS THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
HOUSING. IN A IN SECURITY FOOD
AND SECURITY NESTLE HELP.
GRADUATING YOU KNOW ON TIME.
GIVE US YOUR PERSPECTIVE THINGS
UP AT ABOUT THE SAME OR THINGS
GETTING BETTER THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN WORSE. FOR STUDENTS HOW
HOW WOULD YOU ASSESS THAT. WELL
WHEN IT COMES TO FOOD
INSECURITY I DEFINITELY FEEL
LIKE THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE
IN RESOURCES AVAILABLE FROM MY
FIRST YEAR I HAD NO IDEA WHAT
CAL FRESH WAS BUT THROUGHOUT MY
INVOLVEMENT IN THROUGHOUT ON
THE ORIENTATION SERVICES. THAT
TRYING TO EXPOSE MORE STUDENTS
TO OPTIONS THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE THROUGH COW FRESH
THROUGH THE FOOD PANTRY. SO I
REALLY DO FEEL LIKE OUR
RESPONSE TO FOOD AND SECURITY
HAS BEEN PRETTY ROBUST. AND I
THINK THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS AS MUCH AS WE CAN AT
THIS POINT. I OF COURSE THE
NEXT BIGGEST CHALLENGE I FEEL
LIKE FOR US IS HOUSING AND
SECURITY EVEN THOUGH WE CAN
COLLABORATE AS MUCH AS WE CAN
WITH EXTERNAL PARTNERS WE HAVE
EMERGENCY HOUSING. MOST
STUDENTS DON'T KNOW THE
RESOURCES AND SO. ESPECIALLY IF
I HAD BEEN DOING OUR BEST TO
COLLAPSE BY. WITH OUR STUDENTS
WHICH IS ONE OF THE MAIN
REASONS WE MEET THE- BASIC
NEEDS OFFICER. JUST BECAUSE
THAT'S A REAL BIG FOCUS ON
COMMUNICATION BECAUSE WE CAN
HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES THAT WE
DO HAVE THE COMMUNICATIONS WITH
STUDENTS IS KEY. AND I REALLY
DO FEEL LIKE SI ON PLAYS A
CRUCIAL PART IN THAT. YEAH.
COURSE CAN I ADD TO THAT WE'VE
ALSO COLLABORATED WITH OUR
UNIVERSITY POLICE OF THEY ARE
OUT PATROLLING AND THEY C.
STUDENT WHO POTENTIALLY MAYBE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING AND
SECURITIES THAT THEY PROVIDE
THEM WITH A HANDOUT THAT HAS
OUR RESOURCES AND A RACIAL ONE
BOB I'LL FOLLOW UP FOR ME DO
YOU FEEL LIKE I MEAN THERE'S A
LOT OF STUDENTS THAT THAT THAT
THEY DON'T ENGAGE THEY COME TO
THE CAMPUS WITH BLINDERS ON. BY
THEIR CLASS FIND THE RESTROOM
AND THEN FIND THE CAR AND
THAT'S ALWAYS A CHALLENGE TO
DEAL WITH A LOT OF LEVELS BUT
DO YOU FEEL THAT THE CAMPUS IS
DOING ENOUGH TO CREATE THE
AWARENESS LEVEL AT ALL THESE
ARE THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
HELPING HANDS HERE THAT'S OVER
HERE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE CARE AND WANT TO HELP
DID YOU FEEL LIKE THAT IS
ENOUGH BEING DONE SO THAT THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE HAVE BLINDERS
ON OR WE'RE GETTING IN THEIR
SPACE AND. THE RIGHT WAY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM AND- LET
THEM KNOW. OUR I WAS ASKED TO
GET MY FIRST YEAR I WOULD PARK
COME TO MY CLASS AND LEAVE IT
WAS ONLY THROUGH. THE STUDENTS
WHO ENCOURAGED ME TO GET
INVOLVED BUT I DID GET
INVOLVED. SO I DEFINITELY KNOW
THAT STRUGGLE AND I THINK THE
NEW APPROACH TO MAKING SURE THE
ADVISORS KNOW ABOUT THESE.
RESOURCES AND REALLY CONNECTING
OUR STUDENTS IS WHERE THE MOST
HELP WILL BE BECAUSE STUDENTS
ARE FORCED TO GO. TO ADVISE AND
THEY SHOULD GO TO ADVISING TO
GRADUATE. BECAUSE THE STUDENTS
WERE BLINDERS ARE REALLY ABOUT
GETTING THEIR DEGREE IN GETTING
OUT. SO I THINK THE MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH OF MAKING
SURE ADVISORS KNOW ABOUT ALL OF
THESE RESOURCES AND CONNECTING
STUDENTS. IT'S REALLY A GOOD
PART ESPECIALLY IN CLASS EVEN
THOUGH I HAVE NOT BEEN A PART
OF THE STUDY OR THE CLASS
COACHING BECAUSE I'M A FOURTH
YEAR. THE PART OF MAKING SURE
THAT ADVISERS ARE COACHING THE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS ADVISING
THEM ON THEIR ACADEMICS I THINK
MAKES THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE.
THAT'S CERTAINLY A BIG INDOOR.
SPIN ABOUT DOCTOR LIVING.
PROGRAM. AT HER COLLEGE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A APPLIED
ACROSS THE BOARD TO THE OTHER
COLLEGES HERE BUT CERTAINLY I.
IT'S A GOOD POINT OF
AFFIRMATION FOR THAT GOOD WORK
OF. CONNECTING EVEN IF IT'S ON
THE ACADEMIC SIDE. IT'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY FOR A TOUCH THAT
COULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN A
PERSON'S LIFE. I ATE ABOUT.
THAT'S OKAY I WANT TO OPEN UP
OUR PUBLIC HEARING FOR THOSE
WHO. HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE TO
SHARE SOME THOUGHTS WE- WE ARE
ON A SCHEDULE SO WE ARE OPEN
TO. ASK YOU TO KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS BRIEF BUT- ANYBODY
HERE WOULD LIKE TO SHOW US THE
ANY THOUGHTS WITH US ON THE
ISSUES AT HAND. WHEN WALKING
INTO THE CENTER OF THE- OF THE
ROOM WITH A MICROPHONE IS THERE
TO. FOR ALL OF US. HERE AND
THOSE WATCHING AT HOME TWO.
OTHER OFFICES HERE AS WELL.
ANYONE HAVE ANYTHING THEY WANT
TO COME COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. AND YOU'RE WELCOME
TO SHARE YOUR NAME IF YOU WISH.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON FERMENTERS I
WANT TO HI MY NAME'S FOR CAL
AND I WORK AT COUNSELING AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL SERVICES. AND I'M
ALSO PART OF THE INTEGRATED
CARE NETWORK BACK DOCTOR COULD
TERRACE LOCUS WAS FOUND
REFERRING TO. AND I'VE BEEN
HERE ALMOST ABOUT TWO MONTHS
ANDY TWENTY TWO MONTHS. I'VE
BEEN ABLE TO. I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
LINK STUDENTS THAT DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE. TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BOTH PSYCHIATRIC AND
LONG TERM THERAPY WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY SO THERE ARE SO THERE
IS THAT TYPE OF SERVICE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. I'M ALSO WORKING
WITH SOME STUDENTS ON FINDING
AND REPLYING TO MEDIC CAL FOR
THOSE THAT. DO QUALIFY AND WHAT
ELSE. I THINK A REBOUND
CORONADO WHO'S THE DIRECTOR OF
HE- THE LEAD EXCUSE ME OUT FOR
THE ENIGMA INTEGRATED CARE
NETWORK HAS DONE A REALLY
OUTSTANDING JOB AND FINDING
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. SUCH AS
CHARTER OAK HOSPITAL TRI VALLEY.
I CITY MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER.
MENTAL HEALTH CLINICS SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS ARE SEEN IN GUARANTEED
THAT THE ARE ARE BEING SEEN AND
FOLLOWED UP SO I THINK THAT
SOME REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE YES THEY DO NEED
SERVICES AND SOMETIMES. WE
DON'T WANT THEM TO WAIT SO IF I
HAVE INSURANCE I CAN CONNECT
THEM IF THEY DON'T HAVE
INSURANCE I CAN STILL CONNECT
THEM SO THAT PARTNERSHIP IS
HERE I JOHN M. TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU WERE AWARE. THANK YOU
VERY THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
SECOND ONE UP TO THE MICROPHONE
STUDENTS HERE. THAT THE STAFF
YOU ARE WELCOME TO SHARE YOUR
THOUGHTS HI MY NAME IS DESTINY
VICKERS ON A TRANSFER STUDENT
IS MY FIRST SEMESTER HERE I
JUST KAPALI ONE IS A GREAT
UNIVERSITY I JUST FEEL THAT
THEY CAN BE A LITTLE MORE
PARENT FRIENDLY BECAUSE THERE'S
NO PARENT HOUSING AND I'M
FINDING IT A STRUGGLE TO.
ADJUST THEIR SUPPORT WHAT THE
LIKE OKAY I'M JUST GOING TO
STOP GOING TO SCHOOL BECAUSE
IS. TOO MUCH TO FIND I'M
RELOCATING FROM VICTORVILLE AND
IT'S A. IS DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
FIND HOUSING IMAGE DUTY AND THE
PRESIDENT OUGHT TO BE ABLE WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN HELP ME AS MUCH AS
THEY CAN BUT I FEEL LIKE IF
THERE WAS. A PLACE FOR PARENTS
TO COME TO FEEL MORE WELCOME.
LIKE PERMANENT PARENTING
HOUSING ON CAMPUS OR NEARBY
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING GREAT.
BUT THAT THAT FEEDBACK IS
IMPORTANT AND I IS THERE ANY
KIND OF. PARENTAL APPARENT.
COUNSELING GROUP FOR YES THEY
HAVE THOSE ON CAMPUS AND LIKE I
SAID MISS JUDY AND- OTHER STAFF
ON CAMPUS HAVE BEEN HELPING ME.
BUT IS KIND OF SO MUCH THEY CAN
ONLY DO IT THERE'S NOTHING
PERMANENT FOR. PARENTS THAT OUR
STUDENTS. I THINK I JUST THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MESSAGE
DELIVERED I THINK YOU HAVE A
LOT OF IMPORTANT PEOPLE HERE
AND THAT TODAY THE PERCENTAGE
SHARE US. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
THOUGHTS THEY WANNA SHARE
BEFORE WE FINISH UP OUR HEARING.
A ONE OUT LOUD MY PARTNERS
APPEARS CENTER CHANG AND
SENATOR ROTH TO. MAKE ANY
CONCLUDING REMARKS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE BEFORE WE CLOSE.
SENATOR CHANG. I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR GIVING US THE
INFORMATION REALLY TAKING THAT
UP BACK UP TO SACRAMENTO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK. CENTER CENTER CHECK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
SUPPORT ALL THESE ISSUES AND IN
THE SENATE SHE HAD A- CENTER
ROTH ANY CONCLUDING THOUGHTS.
WELL MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING ME AGAIN IT'S BEEN
VERY VERY INFORMATIVE I LOOK
FORWARD TO. CONTINUING THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL OF YOU.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD INTO THE
INTO THE NEXT FISCAL YEARS OF
BUDGETS. MANY OF THESE ISSUES
ARE BUDGET RELATED AND I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FULLY
EXPLORE THEM AND TRY TO.
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES. THAT YOU
ALL NEED IN ORDER TO AS I SAID
MOVE. THIS INSTITUTION FORWARD
AND- DO THE RIGHT THING FOR THE
NEXT FOR THE FUTURE OF OUR-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AT
CAL POLY POMONA SO THANK YOU
RICHARD. THANK YOU CENTER ROTH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON A WHOLE HOST OF EDUCATION
ISSUES. ON LARGE IN YOUR
POSITION AND SENATE. AND FOR ME
I WANT TO AGAIN. A COMPLIMENT
THAT THE LEADERSHIP HERE ON THE
CAMPUS FOR ALL THE GREAT WORK I
MEAN. IN MANY WAYS CAL POLY
POMONA HAS BEEN A LEADERSHIP
CAMPUS OF THE STATE IN A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES THAN WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. CERTAINLY IN
TERMS OF THE GRADUATION.
INITIATIVE YOU WERE ENGAGED IN
THIS IS ISSUE IT REQUIRED
ATTENTION. LONG BEFORE ANY
OTHER CAMPUS. IN CALIFORNIA WAS
FOCUSED ON AND I APPLAUD YOU
FOR THAT. LEADERSHIP I
CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE TO. SEE
YOU SET HIGHER GOALS BECAUSE I
KNOW YOU'RE CAPABLE AS
UNIVERSITY AND WITH THE GREAT
LEADERSHIP HERE OF DOING EVEN
BETTER FOR THE STUDENTS THAT WE
HAVE. I DO THINK THAT. THERE
THE CONTRACTUAL ELEMENTS OF THE
PROMISE IS SOMETHING THAT. IT
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT PART IN.
GETTING THAT COMMITMENT FROM
STUDENTS TO. TO CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE ACADEMICALLY AND ALSO.
TO GET THAT COMMITMENT FROM THE
INSTITUTION TO BREAK DOWN
BARRIERS THAT ARE THERE. AT
VENICE STUDENT FROM. GRADUATING
IN FOUR YEARS. I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE ON BASIC NEEDS. IT IS A
GROWING PROBLEM. I DON'T THINK
IT'S JUST AN AWARENESS ISSUE
IT'S A PROBLEM. AND KNOW THEIR
STUDENTS CAN'T BE SUCCESSFUL IN
THE CLASSROOM IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SHELTER IN AND- AND
THAT THE NOURISHMENT THAT IT
REQUIRES AND THE MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE THAT A STRESSFUL
ENVIRONMENT WHICH- WE TALK
ABOUT THE WONDERFUL PARTS OF
BEING A CAMPUS COMMUNITY BUT IT
CAN BE VERY STRESSFUL TO. AND
IT DOES CREATE. A LOT OF
BARRIERS TO SUCCESS. AND I
APPRECIATE THE- ENHANCED
RESOURCES THAT YOU. A PRESIDENT
COOLLY BROUGHT TO BEAR HERE IN
THE CAMPUS I HOPE YOU'LL
CONSIDER. OTHER WAYS TO HELP IN
THAT IN THAT SPACE AS WELL AND
FINALLY TO PUT ON A HEARING
LIKE THIS IT DOESN'T HAPPEN
MAGICALLY. WITH US JUST SHOWING
UP. ARE THERE MANY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE HELPED MAKE IT HAPPEN
CERTAINLY PRESIDENT COOLLY YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. AND WONDERFULLY
WELCOMING AND GRACIOUS AND
HOSTING US HERE ROBIN LOPEZ
VALERIE ROSE AVAILABLE OF YOUR
TEAM HERE HAVE BEEN VERY
GRACIOUS AND- HELPING US PUT
THE SIGN. I WANT TO THANK I.
DANA AND FILL FROM OUR AUDIO
VISUAL TEAM FROM THE SENATE TO
ALLOW US NOT TO HAVE THIS.
EVERYBODY HERE EVERYTHING HERE
BUT ACROSS THE STATE THOSE OF
TURNING AROUND CALIFORNIA COULD
BE HERE TODAY HERE IN WATCH.
LISTEN LEARN AS WE HAVE BRIAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP ON THE
TWITTER FEED. AND CERTAINLY OUR
SERGEANT OF ARMS AT TEN KAYLA
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORT YOU'VE
GIVEN US AT TODAY SO WITH THAT
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS IS THE- ON
GOING TO COLLEGE TOUR. WE'RE
NOT DONE YET WE HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN WORK UNIVERSITIES. TO
VISIT IN THE NEXT TWELVE MONTHS.
TO CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION. MAKING SURE
STUDENTS ARE SUCCESSFUL FOR
THAT THIS HEARING IS THE JEFF
THANK YOU